du jour appelle les questions au
Gouvernement et la première d'entre
elles va être posée par Madame la
vice-président rabot
madame la Première ministre la baguette
vient d'être reconnue à l'Unesco et
c'est dans son propre pays la France
qu'elle est en danger aujourd'hui
pourquoi est-ce qu'elle a entendu en
danger parce qu'il y a une explosion des
coudes électricité dans les boulangeries
tout simplement parce que pour faire
cuire du pain il faut un four qui est
une puissance supérieure à celle qui est
permise dans les tarifs réglementés
alors face à cette situation les
boulangers ont deux solutions soit faire
tendre le prix de la baguette vers 2
euros soit mettre la clé sous la porte
ces deux options sont inattendables
madame la Première ministre nous vous le
demandons solennellement avec le groupe
des députés socialistes et apparentés
nous voulons un bouclier tarifaire avec
un tarif réglementé pour les
boulangeries et je souhaite votre
réponse sur ce point je vous remercie
je vous remercie la parole est à
Monsieur Bruno Le Maire ministre lettre
de l'économie des finances et de la
souveraineté industrielle et numérique
ne laisserons tomber aucun boulanger en
France comme nous le laisserons tomber
aucune PME aucune TPE face à
l'augmentation des prix de l'électricité
chez moi-même reçu avec Olivia Grégoire
longuement les représentants des
boulangers Olivia Grégoire les recevra à
nouveau pour trouver des solutions
particulières pour les boulangers qui
effectivement sont confrontés au
problème que vous avez parfaitement
décrit de l'explosion de coup
d'électricité et des fours qui doivent
bien tourner pour faire cuire le pain la
première réponse c'est le guichet que
nous avons mis en place et j'invite
toutes les PME toutes les TPE qui n'ont
pas encore fait elles sont très
nombreuses à venir déposer leurs
factures pour 2022 pour bénéficier des
aides dont elles peuvent bénéficier
jusqu'à hauteur de 4 millions d'euros
ensuite pour l'année 2023 sur la
décision de la première ministre nous
allons tout mettre en place un
amortisseur d'électricité pour toutes
les fameux moins de 250 salariés elles
auront une réduction de leur facture en
moyenne de 20%. si jamais si jamais cela
ne suffit pas nous sommes prêts à
regarder ce qu'il doit être mis en place
de complémentaires pour aider un certain
nombre de professions qui sont
confrontés à des situations
particulières les boulangers en font
partie mais je vous redire avec beaucoup
de gravité beaucoup de sincérité pendant
la crise du covid nous n'avons laissé
tomber aucune PME aucune TP en
difficulté à l'époque c'était
l'hôtellerie la restauration les
services qui étaient en difficulté nous
avons accompagné et bien là face à
l'explosion des prix de l'électricité
qui touchent certaines entreprises très
ciblées la politique reviendra une
nouvelle fois à venir tendre la main et
accompagner ce canon le plus besoin pour
qu'il puisse passer cette période être
au moins de difficultés possible
je vous remercie madame rabot oui
monsieur le ministre vous venez de le
dire vous-même vous allez prendre en
charge 20% seulement de la hausse du cou
alors moi je vais vous donner un exemple
très concret une boulangerie payait 1500
euros par mois de frais d'électricité
cette facture passe à 4500 euros sur les
4500 euros vous allez en prendre à peu
près 900 euros en charge ça veut dire
qu'il lui reste 3600 euros à payer cette
boulangerie sont deux deux à travailler
toute la journée de 4 heures du matin à
19h le soir et bien c'est 3600 euros de
frais d'électricité ils ne peuvent pas
les absorber aujourd'hui et ils vont
fermer début janvier 2023 monsieur le
ministre il y a déjà dans mon
département 5 boulangeries qui ont fermé
5 boulangeries qui sont frappées par la
hausse des coûts de l'électricité alors
il faut que vous nous écoutiez tout de
suite il faut que le tarif réglementé
soit mis en place tout de suite sans
attendre monsieur le ministre sans
attendre vous avez fait référence au
fond de solidarité en disant qu'on a
bien laissé tomber personne le blanc de
la crise sanitaire c'est vrai sauf que
vous avez attendu que vous ne vous
relançons et bien aujourd'hui nous vous
le disons très solennellement sans le
tarif réglementé les boulangeries
fermeront en janvier 2023 et dans nos
communes ce sera une catastrophe je vous
remercie
[Applaudissements]
la parole est à monsieur Sylvain
Maillard pour le groupe Renaissance
merci madame la présidente madame la
Première ministre depuis quelques jours
nous sentons une inquiétude montée chez
nos concitoyens nous observons deux
attitudes d'une part les actions portées
par le gouvernement pour parer aux
difficultés énergétiques et d'autre part
des expressions alarmistes qui
voudraient entretenir la peur en effet
il y a quelques jours le gouvernement a
donné instruction au préfet de
département de préparer des scénarios de
délestage en cas de tension grave sur
nos réseaux d'électricité
l'objectif de cette mesure vise à
prévenir tout risque de coupure
généralisée en janvier qui impacterait
trop fortement le fonctionnement de
notre pays nos concitoyens nos
entreprises nos industries effectuent
depuis plusieurs jours depuis plusieurs
semaines des efforts de sobriété pour
rationaliser nos consommations d'énergie
pourtant dès l'annonce de cette mesure
de précaution certains parmi ceux qui
siègent dans cette hémicycle se sont
acharnés à propager la peur
[Applaudissements]
il faut le dire et le redire autant que
faire ce peu ces informations sont
fausses
nous savons tous que notre politique de
sobriété devrait nous permettre de
passer cet hiver sans coupure
d'électricité
d'ailleurs le scénario d'un délestage au
mois de décembre a été écarté par RTE
mais pour certains groupes politiques la
capacité à prévoir et anticiper tous ces
scénarios serait déjà une faute
notre majorité je vous le dis assume de
tout faire pour protéger nos hôpitaux
nos écoles et l'ensemble de nos services
publics
car les faits sont là malgré la guerre
en Ukraine qui impacte les systèmes
énergétiques de l'ensemble de l'Europe
nous tenons et continuerons à tenir
aussi madame la Première ministre pour
dissiper toute cette news à ce sujet
quelle mesure sont prévues pour ces
télésage comment votre gouvernement va
les anticiper je vous remercie je vous
remercie
la parole est à madame la Première
ministre
merci madame la Présidente Mesdames et
Messieurs les Députés monsieur le député
Sylvain Maillard votre question porte
sur un sujet qui est aujourd'hui dans
l'esprit de beaucoup de Français quelle
sera l'impact de la situation
énergétique dans nos vies quotidiennes
cette question les Français se la pose
quand il s'agit de leur pouvoir d'achat
des enjeux écologiques mais aussi de la
sécurité d'approvisionnement et je peux
vous assurer monsieur le député que le
gouvernement est mobilisé depuis des
mois cette mobilisation se conduit avec
ordre méthode et dans l'anticipation
se mobiliser c'est d'abord nous appuyer
sur EDF et j'ai eu à plusieurs reprises
Luc Raymond le nouveau président de
cette entreprise depuis sa prise de
fonction et je peux vous garantir qu'il
partage la détermination du gouvernement
pour assurer une production
d'électricité maximale de notre
opérateur national en particulier grâce
aux redémarrage de nos réacteurs
nucléaires
partout c'est possible naturellement
dans des conditions de sécurité optimale
les calendriers sont accélérés et les
mois de décembre et de janvier verront
le redémarrage de nombreuses tranches
nucléaires et je peux vous le dire ici
j'ai confiance dans cette entreprise
dans ses agents qui n'ont jamais manqué
à notre pays
ce mobiliser c'est aussi travailler pour
identifier tous les gisements de
production et d'économie possible dans
une période où la tension sera maximale
sur notre réseau c'est partager
également avec nos concitoyens
l'impératif de sobriété comme le
président de la République l'a fait dès
l'été dernier et les Français ont
parfaitement compris cette nécessité
puisque la consommation a baissé de 7% à
météo
identique ce mobiliser c'est aussi la
solidarité européenne nous avons
sécurisé nos interconnexions avec nos
voisins c'est d'ailleurs le sens de
l'accord que j'ai signé avec le
chancelier allemand il y a dix jours se
mobiliser c'est anticiper se donner les
moyens de réagir en cas de tension
accrue par exemple si nous faisons face
à un épisode de température
exceptionnellement rigoureuse c'est pour
cela que nous avons conçu avec RTE
l'outil Ecowatt qui permet d'anticiper
la situation dans les trois jours à
venir alors ça n'est pas un signal
d'alarme c'est un outil de mobilisation
individuelle et parce que ce sont bien
des gestes simples qui seront les plus
efficaces pour nous prémunir d'une
situation critique et puis enfin
anticiper c'est examiner tous les
scénarios fustent-ils inédits improbable
bien évidemment les préfets en lien avec
les collectivités et les associations
étudie comment protéger les Français
notamment les plus vulnérables et
contrairement à ce que des propos
maladroits ont pu laisser penser nos
hôpitaux seront toujours alimentés en
électricité et les personnes malades à
domicile seront toujours prises en
charge donc je le redis notre engagement
de tous les instants c'est de mobiliser
chacun pour assurer la sécurité
d'approvisionnement en électricité notre
responsabilité c'est de planifier tous
les scénarios sans faux semblant mais
sans agiter de fausses paires je vous
remercie
je vous remercie madame la Première
ministre
la parole je vous demande un peu de
calme s'il vous plaît mes chers
collègues et je donne la parole à
Monsieur Hendrick Davy pour le Groupe
LSI
madame la présidente madame la ministre
chers collègue les salariés de GrDF en
grève depuis un mois
occupe depuis hier soir le site de
Marseille en 2000 quand je suis arrivé
on venait du monde entier pour apprendre
les savoir-faire des salariés d'EDF nous
étions un exemple nous étions fiers et
tous les salariés avaient le service
public et service public Chevilly au
corps aujourd'hui il nous prépare à des
coupures de courant dans les écoles
c'est une honte ce sont les mots des
salariés de GrDF que réclame-t-il une
hausse de leur salaire de
4,6%. cela coûterait à peine 18 millions
d'euros alors que GrDF a versé 518
millions de dividendes nous en saurions
pas là si vous aviez lancé des
négociations partout en France pour
indexer les salaires sur l'inflation
comme nous le proposions
pire vous avez choisi la répression
notamment à RTE qui gère le transport de
l'électricité et où une enquête est
ouverte après le suicide d'un salarié
cette situation sociale à grDF et RTE
dit beaucoup de choses de la crise
énergétique que nous traversons d'abord
le mépris des salariés et la casse
méthodique du service public ensuite un
manque cruel de volonté politique pour
développer des énergies renouvelables et
une rénovation globale des bâtiments
encore une fois vous n'avez rien
anticipé des délaissages sont donc
prévus notamment dans les zones rurales
menaçant de désorganiser le pays les
Français sont inquiets pour les patients
hospitalisés à domicile les transports
ou les écoles alors comment gérer la
crise en planifiant CD des stages sur
les activités qui ne sont pas
indispensables comme la publicité et la
pollution lumineuse ou l'activité de
certaines entreprises
pour préserver ce qui est essentiel
comme le chauffage des particuliers les
transports ou les écoles madame la
ministre alors de la crise énergétique
qu'attendez-vous pour donner
satisfaction aux salariés de GrDF et de
RTE c'est la moindre des choses elle est
où elle est où planifier les délaissages
préservant les plus démunis les
activités essentielles et enfin quand
allez-vous recréer un service public
intégré de l'énergie dont notre pays a
tant besoin pour mener à bien la
transition énergétique
je vous remercie la parole est à Madame
Agnès panier rue nation ministre de la
transition énergétique
merci madame la Présidente Mesdames et
Messieurs les Députés monsieur le député
d'avis d'abord votre question me permet
de saluer l'ensemble de la filière
énergétique des salariés qui sont
aujourd'hui au travail chez EDF chez RTE
chez nadis cherdf pour nous préparer
dans les meilleures conditions au
passage de l'hiver et comme vous le
savez la négociation sociale a été
active puisque la branche des yeux g à
négocier dans un temps record un accord
majoritaire qui a été plus que
majoritaire puisqu'il a été signé par
les quatre confédérations syndicales
par ailleurs l'accord chez grd il y a un
accord chez GrDF majoritaire aujourd'hui
et vous savez que chez RTE les
négociations se poursuivent elles ont
été entamées fin novembre et elle se
poursuivent à bon train et je veux
saluer l'esprit de responsabilité des
organisations syndicales qui se sont
mobilisées pour faire en sorte
que c'est négociation aboutissent à bon
terme vous évoquez le sujet de notre
préparation pour l'hiver et notamment de
la sobriété mais je veux dire ici que
c'est ce gouvernement qui souligitte de
la première ministre et de président de
la République ont mis en place un plan
sobriété qui n'est pas juste adressé à
Monsieur et madame tout le monde mais
qui au contraire mobilise les grandes
entreprises les grandes administrations
les collectivités locales de manière à
ce qu'elle baisse de 10% leur
consommation d'énergie dans les deux ans
qui viennent et vous voyez que ce plan
porte ses fruits madame la Première
ministre disait à l'instant que nous
constatons une baisse de 7% pas 7% dans
l'absolu mais 7% corriger des normales
saisonnières et nous allons continuer à
mobiliser pour faire en sorte que ce
plan délivre s'abaisse d'énergie de
manière à nous mettre du côté de la
sécurité et passer en sérénité cet hiver
je veux rappeler ici que les tensions
sur notre système énergétique
qui sont européennes elles ne sont pas
françaises
je vous remercie madame la ministre deux
secondes monsieur
les salariés en grève à Marseille
je vous remercie
la parole est à Monsieur Maxime minot
pour le complet républicain merci madame
la Présidente
ce boulanger au bord des larmes a reçu
comme tous les commerçants artisans de
notre pays le courrier de trop de la
part de EDF le 14 novembre dernier ce
courrier annonçait une hausse
exorbitante des prix de 322%. 322%
madame la Première ministre c'est simple
sur une facture annuelle certains
passeront pour l'année 2023 de 16000
euros à 40000 euros que répondre à ces
fans et ses hommes qui se battent au
quotidien pour survivre eux qui ont déjà
tant souffert durant la crise sanitaire
et qui pour la plupart ont investi
toutes leurs économies dans leur passion
mais au-delà de cette terrible réalité
qui touche bien trop de nos concitoyens
c'est l'avenir du commerce et de
l'artisanat en France qui est en jeu
votre gouvernement s'est saisit bien
trop tard de ce problème et les
dispositifs se succèdent mais ils sont
souvent
inefficaces inadaptées et ils font
beaucoup d'oublier de nombreux artisans
madame la Première ministre depuis
plusieurs semaines et sur ces bancs nous
avons été très nombreux à vous le dire
vous lance un appel au secours ces
personnes qui ne se plaignent jamais se
sont toujours acquittés de leur tâche
avec rigueur acharnement et patr car ils
ont la France chevillé au corps cette
crise nous permet malheureusement de
vous rappeler que oui oui nos artisans
contribuent à Laura de notre pays ils
sont les dernières représentants d'un
savoir-faire de nos territoires et font
vivre chaque jour notre économie locale
alors pourquoi continuer d'indexer le
prix d'électricité sur celui du gaz et
au-delà de cette nécessaire réflexion
sur les prix d'énergie comment
accompagner ses professionnels dans leur
quotidien de façon pérenne sans en
laisser sur le bord du chemin je vous
remercie
je vous remercie la parole est à
Monsieur Bruno Le Maire ministre de
l'économie et des finances et de la
souveraineté industrielle et numérique
monsieur le député la difficulté des
boulangers ne vous autorise pas à dire
n'importe quoi sur l'action de
gouvernement qui depuis plusieurs
semaines discutent avec les boulangers
avec les artisans pour trouver avec eux
des solutions
mais nos amis boulanger avec lesquels
nous sommes en contact régulier avec
Olivier Grégoire depuis plusieurs
semaines sans les premières reconnaître
que la solution d'une extension du TRV à
toutes les TPE n'est pas praticable tout
simplement parce qu'elle coûterait 3
milliards d'euros et qu'elle
couvriraient d'autres entreprises qui
n'en ont absolument pas besoin et qu'il
préfère de manière raisonnable des aides
ciblées sur les boulangers qui en ont le
plus raison et si votre même groupe qui
viendrait ensuite nous reprocher d'avoir
une approche trop globale dans l'aide
qui alimenterait l'inflation au lieu de
faire reculer l'inflation par des
mesures ciblées donc oui nous préférons
en accord avec les boulangers prendre le
temps nécessaire mais monsieur le député
monsieur le député j'étais il y a
quelques jours au téléphone avec
baignade boulanger à
Saint-Pée-sur-Nivelle avec lequel je
regardais ses factures il y a quelques
jours j'étais à Montceau-les-Mines avec
Olivier Grégoire à regarder les factures
des boulangers donc tout somme aussi
près du terrain que vous l'êtes et aussi
qu'on change les difficultés les
boulangers que vous pouvez l'être et
nous leur apporterons des solutions dans
les jours qui viennent pour qu'ils
puissent payer leurs factures faire leur
travail de boulanger et défendre la
boulangerie française
je vous remercie monsieur le ministre
monsieur minot merci madame la
Présidente Monsieur le Ministre votre
agacement et votre aragance cache-t-il
quelque chose aujourd'hui il ne s'agit
pas uniquement de trouver des solutions
d'urgence mais bien de revoir surtout le
calcul du prix de l'électricité
notamment au niveau européen sans ça
nous pouvons craindre le pire monsieur
le ministre ses travailleurs sont
précieux et j'aimerais que vous
compreniez ici que ce n'est pas un cri
d'alarme individuelle mais c'est un cri
de rage de tous les artisans de France
je vous remercie monsieur le ministre
[Applaudissements]
monsieur le député il y a aucune
agressivité de ma part les modifications
européennes vous le savez comme moi elle
prendront des mois ou des années nous
nous voulons des solutions dans les
jours qui viennent comme vous pour les
boulangers je vous remercie monsieur le
ministre
la parole est à président bourlange pour
le groupe démocrate
[Applaudissements]
madame la ministre mes chers collègues
le 39 novembre dernier l'Assemblée
nationale a adopté à l'unanimité la
résolution visant à sanctionner les
airbags à exiger le retrait de ses
forces du territoire arménien
la France a le devoir d'exercer toute sa
solidarité à l'égard de l'Arménie elle
le doit pour des raisons historiques
contenu des épreuves terribles subies
par ce peuple elle ne doit pour des
raisons morales car ce qui est en cause
c'est le principe de nationalité elle le
doit aussi pour des raisons
géopolitiques vis-à-vis un peuple qui
est enclavé isolé perdu au milieu d'un
environnement hostile je voudrais dans
cet esprit vous poser deux questions 1
le gouvernement partage-t-il les
craintes qui sont celles des Arméniens
sont les risques d'une relance imminente
de la guerre par l'Azerbaïdjan les
gesticulations diplomatiques récentes de
ce pays en particulier le refus de
participer au sommet européen prévu à
Bruxelles et surtout le blocage pendant
plusieurs heures du couloir de la Chine
c'est à dire la remise en cause de
l'unité territoriale de l'Arménie ne
sont-ils pas de fort mauvais augures
deuxième question
le gouvernement français entend-il
contribuer aujourd'hui à la préservation
des droits et de l'identité culturelle
voire au maintien dans les lieux à la
survie physique des populations
arméniennes du haut-karaba quelles
efforts des poils pour mettre en place
les garanties internationales qui sont
nécessaires pour assurer cette survie
comment ne pas voir que c'est l'identité
d'un peuple et la survie d'une nation
déjà tragiquement éprouvée par
l'histoire qui se joue aujourd'hui
je vous remercie monsieur le Président
la parole
Madame Catherine Colonna ministre de
l'Europe et des Affaires étrangères
merci madame le Président
bourlange les tensions restent vives
entre les deux pays c'est vrai tant à
leur frontières que dans le haut Karaba
et elle démontre s'il le fallait
l'absence de crédibilité des garanties
de sécurité que la Russie prétendait
apporter dans la région c'est un fait
dans ce contexte la France et l'Union
européenne reste pleinement engagée au
soutien de l'Arménie comme elles le sont
depuis le début l'action du Président de
la République au sommet de Prague le 6
octobre dernier a été décisif pour
obtenir le déploiement d'une mission
d'observation de l'Union européenne qui
est déployée donc opérationnel depuis le
20 octobre
certes quelques incidents subsistent
mais cette mission a réellement limitée
les risques d'escalade en assurant un
suivi de la situation à la frontière
comme c'était nécessaire
cette présence doit se poursuivre aussi
longtemps que nécessaire c'est notre
conviction c'est aussi vous le savez
monsieur le Président le souhait des
Arméniens de nouvelles réunions se sont
tenues ces derniers jours tout récemment
à Bruxelles et à Washington
respectivement sur la délimitation de la
frontière et sur le projet de traiter de
paix c'est nous que cession sont une
chance une chance à saisir le présent de
la République l'a dit au président alief
et l'a dit également au Premier ministre
pas chignon je le répète moi-même
régulièrement à mes homologues et donc
nous continuerons d'aider et nous
continuerons nos efforts en vue du
retour de la paix entre ces deux pays je
remercie je vous remercie madame la
ministre la parole est à madame la
Présidente Le Pen pour le groupe
rassemblement national
merci
merci madame la présidente madame la
Première ministre ici à mort exposé sur
un pont là un autre à l'entrée d'un
bourg il y a deux semaines un quart
scolaire attaqué par une horde de
criminel armée de machettes explosion de
153,5 % du nombre annuel de coeblesses
volontaires sur des personnes de 15 ans
ou plus
ose de
263,8% des vols en 2019 et pourtant nous
sommes dans un département français
l'île de Mayotte est en proie à une
véritable guerre des machettes dans
l'indifférence quasi générale des
pouvoirs publics à Paris la situation de
chaos à Mayotte ne doit pas être
considéré comme lointaine et
ultra périphérique mais comme un effet
de loupe un zoom sur ce qui pourrait
être advenir à l'ensemble du pays le
passage d'un en sauvagement de la
société a une situation de chaos hors de
contrôle du gouvernement
une immigration incontrôlée pesante
voire étouffante sur nos services
publics notamment les maternités avec en
moyenne 30 naissances par jour
77% de la population vivant sous le
seuil de pauvreté une inflation des
prises sans précédent variant de 10 à
20% en comparaison avec la métropole
nous avons tant à faire pour nos
compatriotes d'outre-mer et
particulièrement de Mayotte en matière
de contrôle de nos frontières pour faire
face à l'immigration clandestine de
maintien de la paix d'accès à l'eau
courante ou encore de réintégration des
soignants non vaccinés madame la
Première ministre qu'en est-il des
annonces tonitruantes d'Emmanuel Macron
lors de son déplacement à Mayotte en
octobre 2019 depuis des années nos
compatriotes Mahorais manifestent contre
la sécurité sur l'île et pour
l'application des services régaliens
d'un état digne de ce nom nous entendons
depuis longtemps leur cri d'alerte et
vous madame la Première ministre
l'entendez-vous
je vous remercie
[Musique]
la parole est à madame la Première
ministre merci madame la Présidente et
Messieurs les Députés madame la
Présidente Le Pen alors vous venez de
dresser le tableau de la situation à
Mayotte j'ai eu l'occasion de le dire
notamment lors du congrès des maires
nous sommes particulièrement attentifs
madame la Présidente à la situation à
Mayotte que ce soit sur le plan de la
santé le ministre de la Santé s'y est
rendu il y a quelques jours que ce soit
sur le plan de la sécurité le ministre
de l'Intérieur y a été il y a quelques
semaines et il sera d'ici la fin de
l'année de nouveau que ce soit
évidemment sur la pression migratoire et
je crois qu'il y a sans doute un large
consensus sur ses bancs pour dire que la
situation est très difficile de ce point
de vue à Mayotte et je pense que dans le
débat que nous aurons tout à l'heure
nous pourrons certainement y revenir
donc je peux vous assurer madame la
Présidente Le Pen que ce soit sur les
sujets de santé d'école de développement
économique d'emploi
d'égalité aussi dans l'accès aux
prestations dans l'enjeu majeur de la
sécurité de nos compatriotes de Mayotte
le gouvernement est mobilisé nous sommes
déterminés à apporter des réponses aux
attentes de nos concitoyens je vous
remercie
je vous remercie madame la Première
ministre la parole est à Monsieur
Sébastien jumelles pour le groupe cause
démocratique à parenté les républicaines
madame la Première ministre devant les
menaces de coupure d'électricité et
l'improvisation de votre plante
délestage notre colère est forte notre
colère est froide l'hiver vient et nous
nous savons rien sur la manière dont
nous allons traverser cette sale période
ceux qui ont froid l'hiver le savent
déjà
vous avez montré votre incurie devant
l'explosion des prix qui font mal aux
vies aux industries aux agriculteurs en
vous révélant incapable totalement
incapable de reprendre la main sur le
marché pour protéger le pays mais voilà
que votre impuissance consenti à
incarner un état stratège qui vous
conduit désormais à souffler le chaud et
le froid entre l'alarme aux coupures en
même temps que l'invitation à ne pas
paniquer pour mieux masquer votre
impréparation comme pour le covid après
avoir abîmé l'hôpital vous prétendiez
qu'il n'y avait pas d'autre choix que
les privations de liberté vous
infantilisez les Français vous les
humilier vous les menacez de couper le
jus s'ils ne sont pas exemplaires nous
accusons le président de la République
et son gouvernement d'irresponsabilité
énergétique nous accusons le président
de la République et son gouvernement de
n'avoir rien fait pendant les 8
dernières années pour éviter d'effon de
nos capacités de production nous
accusons le président de la République
et son gouvernement de se résigner à
gérer la peur à défaut de savoir gérer
la crise en écartant délibérément le
Parlement de votre stratégie de
délestage anxiogène nous refusons que la
vie des gens de nos enfants comme celle
des plus fragiles notamment les malades
à domicile soit la variable d'ajustement
de votre impréparation
inflation pénurie de médicaments
urgence qui ferme coupure de courant et
bientôt réforme des retraites qu'on
mériter les français pour que vous les
traitiez de la sorte
je vous remercie la parole est à Madame
Agnès panier renacher ministre de la
transition énergétique
merci madame la Présidente Mesdames et
Messieurs les Députés monsieur le député
jumelles
la France vous le savez se prépare
depuis 9 mois à faire face à cette crise
énergétique qui n'a rien de français
puisque c'est une crise européenne
lorsqu'on dépend à 40 % des livraisons
de gaz de la Russie et lorsque 20% de
l'électricité européenne est produite à
base de gaz par construction nous avons
une crise et c'est ce pays qui a été
l'un des premiers à remplir ces stocks
de gaz au maximum c'est ce pays qui a
pris des mesures au niveau et qui a
conduit des mesures au niveau européen
pour faire face précisément et nous
mettre en situation de passer l'hiver
dans les meilleures conditions de
préparation
c'est ce pays également qui vous a fait
voter cet été un certain nombre de
mesures qui permettent de nous mettre à
l'abri des situations de tension sur
notre réseau électrique dans la plupart
des situations alors Monsieur jumelles
plutôt que de nourrir l'angoisse et
l'anxiété des Français
aidez-nous à mobiliser les entreprises
les administrations les collectivités
locales pour continuer dans la baisse de
leur consommation d'énergie et des nous
à soutenir les salariés d'EDF de RTE
d'enedis de GrDF qui sont aujourd'hui au
travail pour augmenter notre production
d'électricité et pour sécuriser nos
stocks de gaz et dis-nous à faire en
sorte qu'au niveau européen on poursuive
les mesures que nous avons prises et qui
nous mettent en bien meilleure situation
qu'il y a seulement 9 mois car ententons
aujourd'hui parler de télésage de gaz
non et pourtant
une source a disparu et nous est plus
aujourd'hui livré par la Russie pourquoi
nous préparons nous au scénario du pire
parce que nous avons la responsabilité
d'anticiper toutes les situations et en
responsabilité nous travaillons à
protéger les Français en protégeant leur
pouvoir d'achat et en protégeant leur
accès à l'énergie merci madame la
ministre
une
seconde vous préparez le scénario du
pire et vous êtes le pire des scénarios
[Applaudissements]
la parole est à Madame Patricia Lemoine
pour le groupe Renaissance merci madame
la Présidente ma question s'adresse à
monsieur le ministre de l'économie des
finances et de la souveraineté
industrielle et numérique monsieur le
ministre les derniers chiffres publiés
par l'Insee font état d'une inflation à
6,2 % afin octobre avec une hausse des
prix de l'alimentation de plus de 12%.
si ces chiffres restent élevés l'action
massive du gouvernement depuis l'automne
2021 a permis de les juguler grâce
notamment au dispositif visant à limiter
la hausse des prix de l'énergie il
permettent ainsi à notre pays d'afficher
une inflation bien plus faible que celle
de la zone euro qui atteint
11,5% en moyenne avec notamment
l'Allemagne et ses 11,6% ou encore
l'Italie qui grimpe à 12,6%
malgré tout certains secteurs sont
davantage fragilisés c'est notamment le
cas de nos artisans boulangers ou de
nous boucher qui nous alerte de façon
inquiétante sur leur situation en effet
la hausse parfois vertigineuse du coût
des matières premières farine de blé
plus 43% beurre + 21 % conjugué à
l'explosion du coût de l'énergie amène
de nombreux professionnels à
s'interroger sur la poursuite de leur
activité pourtant vital d'autant que
vous nous avez annoncé que le pic de
l'inflation n'était pas encore atteint
il nous expose des situations
ubuesques avec des factures d'énergie
parfois multipliées par 20 c'est le cas
dans ma circonscription monsieur le
ministre je vous ai particulièrement
mobiliser pour accompagner tous nos
petits commerçants qui sont tentés de
plein fouet par cette crise
à l'heure où la baguette vient d'être
classée au patrimoine mondial de
l'UNESCO pouvez-vous nous faire part des
dernières mesures envisagées pour
répondre à l'ensemble de leurs
inquiétudes je vous remercie je vous
remercie la parole est à Monsieur Bruno
Le Maire ministre de l'Économie des
Finances de la souveraineté industrielle
et numérique
que grâce à l'action du gouvernement de
la président de la République depuis
octobre 2021 la France garde le taux
d'inflation le plus faible des pays de
la zone euro nous avons donc protégé nos
compatriotes contre l'impact trop dur de
la flambée des prix pour ce qui est des
boulangers pour entrer un tout petit peu
plus dans le détail le guichet d'aide
est ouvert aujourd'hui pour les factures
2022 mais ce qui les inquiète qu'on
voulait parfaitement dit c'est la
facture 2023 nous leur garantissons déjà
une réduction globale de factures en
moyenne de 20% pour tous les boulangers
qui auront droit à ce tarif préférentiel
de l'électricité en deuxième lieu nous
allons relancer des fournisseurs qui
doivent offrir des offres alternatives
c'est la charte qui était ciée par tous
les fournisseurs en troisième lieu nous
voulons que cette baisse des prix soit
indiquée dans le projet de facture 2023
pour alléger l'inquiétude des boulangers
qu'il sache exactement ce qu'ils vont
payer plutôt que le tarif indicatif
souvent aux heures pleines et au moment
de plus votre consommation qui leur est
indiqué ensuite si nous voyons que pour
un certain nombre de profession et je
pense en particulier au boulanger
l'ensemble de ces mesures transversales
ne sont pas suffisantes nous sommes
prêts avec la première ministre à
étudier des mesures complémentaires je
le redis nous ne laisserons pas tomber
les boulangers de France la seule chose
que j'exclus et que d'ailleurs les
boulangers ont parfaitement compris
c'est une augmentation globale des TRV
sur toutes les entreprises à 3 milliards
d'euros qui revient à gaspiller l'argent
public et à augmenter les impôts des
français derrière pour rembourser la
facture les boulangers ne souhaitent pas
ce n'est pas ce que nous ferons c'est
des ni efficace ni juste ni cibler nous
privilégierons des mesures efficaces
juste rapides et ciblées je vous
remercie monsieur le ministre la parole
est à Monsieur Laurent Pagny fous pour
le groupe liberté indépendant outre-mer
et territoires
madame la présidente madame la Première
ministre mesdames messieurs les
ministres chers et chers collègues cette
question s'adresse à Monsieur le
Ministre de la Santé souvent tabou les
troubles psychiques concernent pourtant
13 millions de Français soient presque 1
sur 5 la pandémie de covid-19 n'a fait
qu'aggraver l'état de santé mentale
d'une grande partie de la population
française fragile notre jeunesse n'a
malheureusement pas été épargné par un
pauvre de la médecine aujourd'hui
sinistrée la pédopsychiatrie manque
cruellement de moyens et d'effectif
cette pénurie a ainsi des conséquences
dramatiques allongement des délais
d'attente risque de ne pas détecter les
troupes psychiques chez les jeunes mais
aussi augmentation des inégalités
territoriales dans mon département
l'Ariège les structures qui gèrent ces
centres dédiées à l'accompagnement
alerte les familles doivent atteindre
plus d'un an pour rencontrer un médecin
ou un psychologue et près de quatre mois
entre cette première rencontre et les
bilans proposition de soins et
d'accompagnement pour leurs enfants
faute de professionnelle spécialisée de
médecins de psychomotricien
orthophoniste psychologue ou infirmier
les orientations et prise en charge
souhaitée s'avère dégrader voire
impossible il devient difficile de
suivre les jeunes notamment dans les
départements où l'on constate la quasi
disparition des pédopsychiatres c'est le
cas en Ariège monsieur le ministre les
soignants sont en grande difficulté
étirent la sonnette d'alarme les enfants
souffrant de troubles psychiques leurs
parents souvent totalement démunies face
à la maladie de leur enfant subissent
tous les jours ce manque
d'accompagnement alors que les fils
d'attente s'allonge dans les centres
médico-psychologiques et
médico-psycho-pédagogique ma question
est donc simple monsieur le ministre
pouvez-vous nous dire quelle est la
stratégie du gouvernement pour répondre
rapidement à la crise profonde que
traverse la pédopsychiatrie en France je
vous remercie
je vous remercie la parole est à
Monsieur François Braun ministre de la
santé et de la prévention
mesdames et messieurs les députés
monsieur le député PANI fou
vous savez la pédopsychiatrie plus
largement la prise en charge de la santé
de l'enfant est une de mes priorités
d'autant que et vous l'avez vous l'avez
signalé les résultats posts crise covid
en tout cas post phase aigu de la crise
covid ont une dégradation de la santé
mentale des enfants et des adolescents
et en particulier des jeunes filles les
assises de la santé mentale de septembre
21 nous ont déjà permis de faire un
certain nombre d'actions à destinations
de ce secteur le numéro national de
prévention du suicide des moyens
financiers humains mis au niveau des
centres médico-psychologiques mais
également au niveau des maisons des
adolescents avec un objectif que nous
atteindrons à la fin de l'année d'au
moins une Maison des Adolescents par
département à côté de cela le dispositif
mon psy a permis de rembourser 95
000 consultations déjà y compris bien
sûr chez les enfants et le développement
des infirmières en pratique avancées en
psychiatrie va permettre là aussi de
répondre un peu mieux aux besoins de
santé de cette jeune population pour
autant c'est insuffisant et nous devons
continuer à avancer comme je m'y suis
engagé je lance demain les assises de la
pédiatrie et de la santé de l'enfant
avec une réunion de l'ensemble des
partis prenantes la semaine prochaine
pour une analyse et trouver des
solutions et mettre en place ces
solutions de façon transversale sur
l'ensemble des champs de la santé de
l'enfant dont bien entendu un champ
spécifique autour de la santé mentale de
l'enfant temps en prévention quand
thérapeutique ces résultats comme je
l'avais déjà annoncé ici seront
disponibles à partir du printemps avec
une feuille de route pour les années à
venir sur l'ensemble de la santé de
l'enfant et particulièrement donc la
santé mentale des enfants et des
adolescents
je vous remercie monsieur le ministre la
parole est à Madame Julie lernous pour
le groupe écologiste
merci madame la Présidente ma question
s'adresse à madame la ministre de la
transition énergétique madame la
ministre fin août le président affirmait
ne vouloir faire preuve d'aucune
faiblesse d'aucun esprit de
compromission à l'égard de l'agresseur
russe en ce sens depuis hier plus aucun
navire transportant du pétrole russe ne
peut débarquer dans un port européen
pourtant d'autres navires russes
continuent à nous alimenter en énergie
comme la révélé Greenpeace des
cargaisons remplies d'uranium sont
arrivés ou partis du port de Dunkerque
le 25 août le 13 et 28 septembre ainsi
que le 29 novembre dernier
preuve du business qui se poursuit avec
rosatum
rosatum c'est la géante russe de
l'industrie nucléaire civile et
militaire
rosatum c'est l'entreprise fondée par
Vladimir Poutine pour se servir ses
intérêts géopolitiques rosatum c'est la
firme qui occupe depuis des mois la
centrale de zaporigia et fait subir des
traitements inhumains aux employés
Ukrainiens madame la ministre le 4
octobre vous affirmiez que nous
n'apportions pas d'uranium russe
pourtant la filière d'EDF Framatome a
récemment confirmé que le commerce du
nucléaire se poursuit avec la Russie
l'État français actionnaire majoritaire
d'EDF pouvait-il l'ignorer
ces livraisons ont-elles pu être faites
sans votre aval nous avons besoin de
clarté pouvant pouvez-vous lever
l'opacité sur les pratiques de
l'industrie nucléaire française quel est
le montant exact et le contenu de ces
contrats et pourquoi le gouvernement ne
met pas un coup d'arrêt à ce commerce
même en période de guerre le nucléaire
semble bénéficier d'un régime
d'exception n'est-ce pas la preuve de
notre dépendance totale à des puissances
étrangères pour faire tourner nos
centrales et nous fournir en électricité
je vous remercie je vous remercie
la parole est à Madame Agnès panière une
ministre de la transition énergétique
merci madame la Présidente Mesdames et
Messieurs les Députés madame la députée
la r.o.s je veux quand même remettre les
choses en perspective très clairement
d'abord la France a négocié des
sanctions contre la Russie ce sont des
sanctions qui visent à atteindre
l'économie russe et les décideurs russes
pour les ramener à la table de
négociation et la France sera
intransigeante sur les respects de ces
sanctions deuxièmement sur la question
de l'uranium je vais être très clair
aussi comme je l'ai été depuis ma prise
de fonction la France n'est pas
dépendante de la Russie pour le
fonctionnement de son parc
électronucléaire et comme j'ai déjà eu
l'occasion de le dire par le passé nous
n'apportons pas en 2022 d'uranium
naturel venant des mines russes pour les
besoins du parc nucléaire français comme
ça des choses sont claires et elles sont
dites
alors je veux également rappeler que au
niveau européen d'autres pays sont
aujourd'hui dépendants de la Russie et
que précisément la France peut jouer ce
rôle de reconstruire la souveraineté
européenne en matière de nucléaire et
d'uranium et que c'est dans un des
enjeux sur lequel nous travaillons nous
avons diversifié nous notre nos
approvisionnements en matière d'uranium
naturel nous sommes en train de
construire une filière complète sur la
question du recyclage de l'uranium et
nous serons demain le fer de lance de
cette souveraineté nucléaire dont je
rappelle qu'elle nous fournit
aujourd'hui 70% de notre électricité une
électricité compétitive une électricité
bas carbone une électricité qui profite
à l'ensemble des Français
je vous remercie madame la ministre
la parole est à monsieur Alexandre
SABATOU pour le groupe rassemblement
national
merci madame la Présidente cette
question s'adresse à madame la ministre
de la transition énergétique madame la
ministre et semaine se suivaient sur
ressemblent au moment où la France doit
affronter la crise énergétique majeure
que vous avez largement provoquée Marine
Le Pen et les députés du rassemblement
national non eu de cesse de vous avertir
sur cette situation catastrophique mais
madame la ministre de semaine en semaine
vous nous baladez sans donner la moindre
réponse au problème des Français le 25
novembre dernier la France et
l'Allemagne ont scellé un accord
d'échange la France devant livrer une
partie de ses réserves de gaz contre de
l'électricité allemande un accord aux
abords simple mais au contour flou et
imprécis malgré nos questions
récurrentes en commission dans
l'hémicycle ou à Matignon lors
d'entretien avec Marine Le Pen vous
refusez de donner les conditions
précises d'application de cet accord la
France livre déjà depuis mi-octobre son
gaz c'est un fait quelles sont les
conditions économiques et financières de
cet accord quelles sont les obligations
réelles de l'Allemagne sur leur
livraison l'électricité nous nous
inquiétons car des personnes chez EDF
nous ont alerté que les Allemands
prétextes régulièrement des problèmes
techniques pour ne pas nous livrer de
l'électricité quand notre réseau est
sous tension ces incertitudes sont
scandaleuses quand on voit le risque de
coupure d'électricité et l'explosion des
coûts de la facture énergétique de nos
entreprises je pense au boucher et
charcutiers qui ont manifesté la semaine
dernière pour la première fois depuis 30
ans je pense à tous les petits
commerçants artisans boulangers je pense
à flexico une PME de 250 salariés à une
en ville dans ma circonscription fleuron
français de l'emballage au 200 brevet
internationaux dont la facture
énergétique va largement dépasser ses
bénéfices c'est une cascade de faillite
et un chômage de masse que nous allons
devoir affronter
madame la ministre quelle garantie
avons-nous que l'électricité allemande
nous soit livrée quand notre pays en
aura besoin quelles sont les conditions
que vous avez négociées il est temps de
répondre à la représentation nationale
je vous remercie
la parole est à Madame ma nièce panier
rue nation ministre de la transition
énergétique
merci madame la Présidente Mesdames et
Messieurs le député monsieur le député
SABATOU avec le RN on n'est jamais déçu
car quand il s'agit d'agiter les peurs
et d'affoler les Français on trouve
toujours fort à prendre par contre quand
il faut en responsabilité voter un
projet de loi qui permet de produire de
l'électricité bas carbone compétitive là
on a plus de répondant ça c'est le vrai
visage du rassemblement national alors
pour répondre à votre question monsieur
SABATOU
si je peux me permettre premièrement il
ne vous a pas échappé que nous avons
aujourd'hui rempli au maximum de
stockage de gaz et qu'effectivement nous
soutenons l'ensemble de l'Union
européenne en exportant du gaz nous le
faisons au conditions du marché vous
m'interrogez sur l'accord avec
l'Allemagne il se trouve que ça concerne
ses exportations de gaz nous le faisons
aux conditions du marché et cela nous
permet de garantir une meilleure
production d'électricité sur l'ensemble
de l'Europe puisque 20% de l'électricité
européenne est produite à base de gaz
deuxième élément s'agissant des
engagements de l'Allemagne je veux vous
préciser ici que l'Allemagne s'est
engagée à prolonger l'utilisation leur
centrale nucléaire qui sont aujourd'hui
en base pour 300 grammes nucléaires et
qui permet justement de sécuriser les
interconnexions avec la France cet
accord là nous l'avons arraché avec le
président de la République et la
première ministre et ce qui nous permet
là encore en sécurité d'affronter dans
les meilleures conditions l'hiver alors
vous voyez que l'Europe cela nous permet
non seulement d'être plus fort pour
faire face à la crise énergétique mais
également de garantir et du gaz et de
l'électricité au français dans les mois
qui viennent je vous remercie madame la
ministre
la parole est à Monsieur Didier Le Maire
pour le Copa horizon
madame la Présidente Monsieur le
Ministre de l'Intérieur chers et chers
collègues comme beaucoup de nos
concitoyens je suis inquiet des coupures
d'électricité à venir qui peuvent durer
certes de deux minutes à deux heures
malheureusement on ne peut pas se
contenter d'espérer qu'il ne se passe
pas de drame durant ses coupures ce quel
que soit la durée en matière de gestion
de crise la chance n'a pas sa place et
la prévention reste son meilleur atout
j'ai lu avec attention la note des
préfets de zones les préfets sont en
train de travailler à la mise en place
de dispositifs adapté au cas où les
dispositifs d'appel de secours les
numéros d'urgence 15 17 18 ou 112 ne
pourrait pas fonctionner
il se trouve que et je m'en réjouis les
maires sont à nouveau au cœur du
dispositif et je fais partie de ceux qui
pensent que on peut trouver des
solutions locales aux enjeux nationaux
j'ai d'ailleurs eu l'occasion d'échanger
avec votre conseiller monsieur ministre
de la Sécurité civile sur ces sujets
demandez au maire de mettre en oeuvre
des cellules de crise implique une
connaissance fine de leur part des
différents dispositifs et mode
opératoires relatifs à la sécurité
civile
or on sait qu'il existe bon nombre de
plans et dispositifs qui sont soit
méconnus soit inappropriés au fil du
temps
monsieur le ministre vous le savez mieux
que quiconque la gestion de crise ne
s'improvise pas alors Monsieur le
Ministre comment comptez-vous
communiquer auprès de nos concitoyennes
et concitoyens sur cet événement et
comment comptez-vous accompagner les
maires pour faire face à ces nouveaux
défis auxquels nous serons confrontés de
plus en plus souvent je vous remercie je
vous remercie merci monsieur le député
la parole est à Monsieur Gérald Darmanin
ministre de l'Intérieur et des Outre-mer
merci madame la Présidente Mesdames et
Messieurs les Députés monsieur le
députés sous l'autorité de la première
ministre les préfets de la République et
avec eux les policiers les gendarmes les
pompiers en lien avec bien sûr les
départements se préparent à scénario
effectivement qui mènerait le délestage
à empêcher une partie du fonctionnement
classique de la vie des Français d'abord
je veux dire comme vous l'avez dit que
les préfets ont rendu les copies à
madame la Première ministre et la
cellule interministérielle de crise qui
a été créé par la première ministre au
ministère de l'Intérieur pour suivre que
dans chacun des départements nous
connaissions les édifices publics qui
sont évidemment ceux qui permettent la
vie de protection des Français les
commissariats les brigades de
gendarmerie mais également les centres
d'appel 17 ou les centres d'appel 18
pour ce qui concerne des pompiers en
lien avec les départements et en lien
particulier avec les maires comme vous
l'avez dit
l'appel de des Français dans les numéros
d'urgence doit être le 112 dans ces
moments de particuliers et ils le savent
déjà c'est français il utilise ce numéro
qui a interopérable et nous nous
permettons nous de répartir ensuite ces
numéros selon les divers services
notamment ceux du ministère de la Santé
en cas de difficulté particulière il
existe déjà aujourd'hui monsieur le
député des zones blanches qui empêche le
concitoyens d'appeler ces numéros ou des
moments particuliers nous les avons vécu
voilà quelques semaines lorsqu'il y a
une crise d'un opérateur téléphonique en
particulier et elle a demandé la
première ministre nous allons d'une part
nous avons équipé d'une part en groupe
électrogène tous les sites du ministère
de l'Intérieur et notamment les forces
de l'ordre pour répondre aux diverses
questions que vous posez mais aussi nous
allons renforcer de manière considérable
les brigades de gendarmerie et les
commissariats de police pour pouvoir
être en cas de zone blanche intempestive
au rendez-vous de nos concitoyens soit
directement auprès des élus et des
témères notamment que vous évoquez soit
évidemment en ouvrant tous les lieux de
service public dans ces difficultés là
je vous remercie monsieur le Maire non
donc la parole est à Monsieur Jean-Luc
grattement pour le groupe la France
insoumise
madame la Présidente ma question
s'adresse à monsieur le ministre
monsieur le ministre en outre-mer
interpellé sur l'envolée des prix des
billets d'avion jusqu'à 42 %, vous nous
avez vous nous avez promis des solutions
interpellées sur les prix élevés de la
téléphonie d'Internet vous nous aviez
promis des solutions interpellées sur
les coups de et les taxes des colis
postaux même réponse sur les prix des
loyers sur les matériaux de construction
et de bricolage pouvant aller jusqu'à 50
à 80% plus cher vous nous aviez promis
des solutions pareil sur les prix des
médicaments des mutuelles des banques
les prix des pièces automobiles jusqu'à
100% plus cher chez nous trouvez-vous
normal qu'en comparaison d'une grande
surface à la Réunion et à Évry sur Seine
le lait en poudre troisième âge coûte 40
poissons plus cher à la Réunion 75%, le
pack de 16 août 16 yaourts aux fruits
les 500 g de spaghetti 40% plus cher
chez nous le paquet de Dylan rasoir 3,29
le pack de 4 coûte jusqu'à 7 euros 99 en
outre-mer qu'on trouve le paquet de
protection hygiénique à 2,14 ici et à
3,90 € 98 chez nous soit 86 % plus cher
vous promettez des réponses pour ce
jeudi mais dans une prestationale vous
donnez déjà des éléments de votre Dino
du pouvoir d'achat le compte n'y est pas
monsieur le ministre
votre montagne de solution accouche
d'une souris à ce stade pas assez sur
les prix et puis vous faites mine
d'ignorer que le pouvoir d'achat c'est
aussi les revenus rien sur les minimas
sociaux rien pour les personnes
âgées et retraités rien pour les
étudiants rien pour les smicards
pensez-vous réellement qu'en outre-mer
on peut vivre avec ce SMIC monsieur le
ministre mais vous avez encore 48 heures
pour revoir votre copie allez vous le
faire monsieur le ministre cessez
d'abandonner les outre-mer
je vous remercie monsieur le député la
parole est à Monsieur Jean-François
kareenko ministre délégué chargé des
Outre-mer
[Applaudissements]
madame la Présidente Monsieur le Député
nous étions engagés avec Gérald
Darmanin sur ce que nous avons appelé le
dino du pouvoir d'achat vous êtes
impatient j'en suis heureux et moi aussi
la priorité première
la priorité première était de parvenir
des accords de modération des coûts des
produits de grande consommation
des chartes territorialisées ont été
signés dans toutes les collectivités
concernées elles sont issues de
négociations locales conduite par les
préfets regroupant l'ensemble des partis
prenantes à la fixation des prix les
acteurs économiques et pour la première
fois les collectivités ont joué le jeu
au niveau territorial je vous rappelle
que ce sont elles qui fixent au niveau
de l'octroi de mer j'ai donc demandé à
celle-ci de participer à cet effort en
modérant leur niveau d'octrodemer qui
pèse sur les prix il faut d'ailleurs
noter que les recettes d'octroi de mer
payées par le consommateur sont en aide
progression plus 11% au premier semestre
2022 nous avons attendu
les décisions des assemblées
délibérantes en la matière tout cela se
négocie il ne suffit pas de dire faites
payer moins pour cela marche peut-être
s'avancer moins vite que prévu mais dès
le 8 décembre avec Gérald Darmanin nous
présenterons les résultats de ce travail
sur ce qu'on appelle le bouclier
qualité-prix il a été élargi à de
nouvelles références adaptées aux
consommations locales on y trouve
également des produits de bricolage
multimédia des services automobiles des
forfaits téléphoniques ces services
ajoutés ont fait l'objet d'un engagement
quant à la modération de leur prix tout
ça est une étape il y a encore des
progressions mais juste un mot sur les
paquets évoqués vous savez que la
solution a été trouvée et que dorénavant
les taxes seront payées uniquement
au-delà de 400 euros au lieu de 200
euros auparavant partout nous avançons
merci de nous aider merci aux
collectivités pour lesquelles vous
travaillez de nous aider aussi je vous
remercie monsieur le ministre la parole
est à Monsieur Bertrand sort pour le
comprenez naissance
merci madame la Présidente mes chers
collègues
ma question s'adresse c'est madame la
secrétaire d'État chargée de l'économie
sociale et solidaire et de la vie
associative madame la ministre depuis
1985 l'Organisation des Nations Unies à
proclamé la journée du 5 décembre
Journée internationale du bénévolat et
des volontaires
je tiens ici à saluer les 20 millions de
bénévoles associatifs pour leur
dévouement et pour leur engagement
car nous le savons toutes et tous dans
cette émission les associations les
bénévoles et les volontaires sur le cœur
battant de notre République à cet effet
madame la ministre vous avez commandé un
sondage en vue de cette Journée mondiale
pour mesurer l'engagement des Français
et nous pouvons dire qu'ils ont du cœur
il en ressort que 49% de nos concitoyens
se déclarent engagés dans une
association locale ou nationale les
associations préférées des Français sont
notamment les Restos du Coeur la SPA la
Croix Rouge la Ligue contre le cancer ou
encore les banques alimentaires
vous les avez d'ailleurs reçu hier et
aussi annoncer le futur lancement des
Assises de la simplification
administrative vous le soulignez
vous-même il y a trop de paperasses dans
la vie associative et bien souvent les
petites structures se heurtent à cette
difficulté et leur bénévoles déplore
cette lourdeur
lors du précédent quinquennat est sous
l'impulsion de Sarah et Larry des
mesures pour faciliter la vie de nos
associations ont été adoptées par notre
majorité mais des simplifications sont
encore à mettre en œuvre enfin ce
sondage révèle également l'attachement
de nos concitoyens à leur territoire et
l'importance que joue le maillage
territorial du tissu associatif face à
ces constats et à cette envie
d'engagement de nos compatriotes les
politiques publiques en faveur de la vie
associative doivent être au rendez-vous
aussi madame la ministre pouvez-vous
nous faire savoir quel sera votre
feuille de route pour ce nouveau
quinquennat je vous remercie je vous
remercie la parole est à Madame Marlène
Schiappa secrétaire d'État chargé de
l'économie sociale et solidaire et de la
vie associative merci madame la
Présidente Mesdames et Messieurs les
Députés monsieur les députés sœurs je
vous remercie pour votre question
effectivement hier c'était la journée
mondiale des bénévoles et des
volontaires d'ailleurs le président de
la République s'est exprimé en soutien
vis-à-vis de ses bénévoles puisqu'une
grande plupart des Français sont
bénévoles le palmarès et l'étude à
laquelle vous faites référence que nous
avons révélé hier montre que près d'un
Français sur deux est engagé auprès
d'une association engagée ça peut
vouloir dire bénévole ça peut vouloir
dire aussi donateur et je rappelle ici
qu'à l'approche de la fin de l'année il
reste encore quelques semaines pour
faire des dons aux associations et
bénéficier déduction d'impôts des
dispositifs comme France générosité
loaso dont en confiance peuvent vous y
aider c'est vrai que les associations
plébiscitées par les Français sont les
restos du cœur la SPA la Croix-Rouge la
Ligue contre le cancer les Banques
Alimentaires nous étions d'ailleurs avec
la première ministre et le ministre des
Solidarités auprès des banques
alimentaires pour dévoiler le fond de la
première mise de 60 millions d'euros en
soutien à ses associations engagées je
veux dire qu'effectivement nous
souhaitons dans la droite ligne de mon
excellente prédécesseur Sarah Léry
poursuivent le travail de simplification
les assises de la simplification
permettront d'y travailler en
interministérielle hier d'ailleurs je
remercie les députés qui sont est devenu
décorer des bénévoles d'associations
mais aussi les ministres Jean-Christophe
conte Stanislas Guerini Jean-Noël
Barraud pour leur présence et leur
engagement pour dématérialiser pour
aller vers un guichet unique et pour en
finir avec l'excès de paperasse et
l'inflation normative en direction des
associations et qu'on puisse enfin
dématérialiser numériser aller vers des
guichets uniques pour les subventions
bref simplifier la vie et là les gel la
charge mentale des dirigeants
associatifs alors je vous remercie pour
votre engagement je suis à la
disposition des députés qui souhaitent
que nous puissions aller saluer et
valoriser les associations sur leur
circonscription vive les bénévoles et
vive les associations je vous remercie
madame aminéstre la parole est à
Monsieur Jean-Louis Bricout pour le
groupe liberté indépendant outre-mer et
territoire merci madame la Présidente ma
question s'adresse madame la ministre de
la transition énergétique j'ai associé
mon homonyme gris Bricout et mon
collègue Benjamin sa tuile madame la
ministre nous sommes bons derniers en
Europe en matière de déploiement des
énergies renouvelables pourtant et c'est
là tout le paradoxe certains territoires
sont déjà trop abîmés par l'éolien bien
sûr il ne faut produire plus d'énergie
décarbonée bien sûr il nous faut
répondre à la demande croissante des
usages électriques et chacun sait que le
nucléaire ne pourra pas y répondre
immédiatement mais nous ne pourrons pas
accroître la production d'énergie verte
sans travailler à son acceptabilité chez
nous dans les Hauts-de-France et chez
moi dans la tirage chez le Vermandois
une éolienne de plus c'est souvent une
éolienne de trop cette transition madame
la ministre vous ne pourrez la faire
sans les territoires sans respecter les
élus sans respecter leur population sans
respecter leurs projets sans respecter
leur paysage vous proposez dans votre
projet de loi un dispositif de
planification mais celui-ci réé est
encore incomplet certes les élus
pourront définir des zones
d'accélération et depuis la loi 3DS des
zones l'exclusion mais quand sera-t-il
des petites communes des peu-vus de
pluie ou de pluie pour adosser ses
honnages comment s'assurer d'une
répartition harmonieuse de l'éolien sont
nos territoires
je vous remercie
mon cher collègue la parole est à Madame
ma nièce panier une ministre de la
transition énergétique
il avait pu
merci madame la Présidente Mesdames et
Messieurs les Députés monsieur le député
Brico merci d'abord pour votre question
qui permet d'évoquer le système de
planification
énergétique nous sommes en train de
construire dans le cadre du projet de
loi sur les énergies renouvelables et je
tiens à vous remercier pour votre
engagement pour développer ces énergies
renouvelables car vous êtes bien placé
pour connaître effectivement la
situation de saturation sur certains
localisations du territoire des
Hauts-de-France mais vous êtes aussi à
la manoeuvre pour faire en sorte qu'on
continue à déployer les énergies
renouvelables toutes les énergies
renouvelables les éoliennes marines le
biométhane la géothermie le
photovoltaïque car c'est bien toutes ces
énergies renouvelables que nous voulons
aujourd'hui accélérer alors vous l'avez
dit cette planification elle perdrait
voir deux principes très simples d'abord
ce sont les maires qui définissent les
zones où ils veulent accélérer les
énergies renouvelables et ce sont
également les mers qui définissent les
zones où ils veulent limiter
l'implantation d'énergie renouvelable et
grâce à cette planification ne leur
redonnons les moyens de définir ces
zones et d'être les derniers décideurs
de porter un avis conforme sur ce jeune
âge par ailleurs vous le savez nous
prenons en compte dans les objectifs de
développement des énergies renouvelables
qui a déjà été fait ce qui a déjà été
fait c'est à la fois
l'importance du déploiement des énergies
renouvelables sur un territoire en
termes de puissance installée en termes
de production mais c'est aussi l'impact
paysager nous avons voté hier la prise
en compte de l'impact paysager dans le
Scott vous posez la question des
communes qui n'ont pas de document
d'urbanisme pour celle-ci dans le cadre
du Schéma départemental que nous allons
mettre en oeuvre et qui sera définie à
la maille géographique de chaque
département nous aurons la possibilité
de mettre en avant ces zones
d'accélération qui sont proposées en
priorité porteurs de projet
bénéficiant de soutien de l'apport de
l'Etat et effectivement leur permettant
de se protéger par rapport à un
développement anarchique
[Musique]
et bien gentil mais je crois que c'est
incomplet le groupe l'odeur nous a
proposé des solutions de régulation on
vous a demandé la définition d'un taux
d'effort sur les territoires ou la mise
en place de malus sur les appels
d'offres dans les zones saturées
d'autres ont proposé de se baser sur un
indice de saturation visuelle je crois
qu'il reste encore beaucoup de pistes à
explorer madame la ministre sur ces
points comme sur la situation
particulière des zones non
interconnectées le vote de notre groupe
se fera au regard de votre niveau
d'acceptation de nos propositions je
vous remercie je vous remercie mon cher
collègue la parole est à Madame Sandra
rigole pour le groupe écologiste
[Applaudissements]
je ne veux plus madame la Présidente je
ne veux plus d'ici la fin de l'année
avoir des hommes et des femmes à la rue
Emmanuel Macron 2017 le résultat 4
millions de personnes mal logées 300 000
personnes sans domicile 600 morts chaque
année à la rue partout force de police
association collectivités
seuls sans être réel du gouvernement
comme à Strasbourg il est loin le temps
des promesses à Strasbourg donc malgré
une action volontariste de la ville 500
nouvelles places d'hébergement et
ouverture de gymnase les moyens d'une
mairie ne peuvent absolument pas suffire
à répondre à une crise humanitaire la
mise à l'abri relève des compétences de
l'État et pourtant pourtant Monsieur le
Ministre la préfecture ne laisse aucun
répit et exige le cacher cette misère
loin du centre-ville au détriment des
devoirs de l'État sur ordre pourquoi
c'est une première question en réponse
la mère de Strasbourg Jeanne barzégan
entend une action responsabilité de
l'État et je voulais lui dire merci
merci envie de le faire pour nous toutes
et tous merci de le faire par refus de
la fatalité que vous n'avez pas parce
qu'on ne peut laisser le pays des Droits
Humains oubliés ce qu'ils font notre
République c'est notre histoire c'est ce
qui fait que nous défendons les
Ukrainiens les Iraniennes et si on
oublie qui nous sommes qu'est-ce qui
nous reste alors le campement de
l'étoile à Strasbourg n'est que la
partie visible de l'iceberg le nombre de
personnes sont abris explose partout des
centaines de jeunes des enfants à la rue
dénoncent en ce moment de l'inhumanité
de leurs conditions de vie devant le
Conseil d'État comme à Strasbourg oui ce
sont des familles et des enfants qui
sont sous ces tentes alors Monsieur le
Ministre cher gouvernement comptez-vous
laissez vos préfets continuer à cacher
la misère ou nous aider à sauver des
vies
je vous remercie la parole est à
Monsieur Olivier Klein ministre de la
Ville et du logement
madame la Présidente
Présidente Mesdames et Messieurs les
Députés madame la député rogolff vous
parlez de fraternité vous parlez de
dignité la première des dignités je
crois que ça donne pas essayer de faire
un coup politique sur une situation qui
est inacceptable et une humaine
absolument c'est la situation oui la
situation de Strasbourg nous la
connaissons depuis trop longtemps la
situation de Strasbourg et de ce camp
est une situation insupportable madame
madame
l'état propose des solutions à proposer
des solutions à Strasbourg à travailler
avec la ville de Strasbourg et les et
les oui madame je vais madame
laissez-moi répondre s'il vous plaît
l'État a proposé des solutions les
familles les ont refusé et celles qui
les ont acceptées ont été immédiatement
remplacés par d'autres familles car la
mère de Strasbourg a refusé d'assumer
ses responsabilités vous savez qu'il y a
un doigt un droit particulier en Alsace
et en Moselle la possibilité de
substitution de n'existe pas donc
c'était à la mère de Strasbourg de
lancer les procédures d'évacuation et
d'ailleurs elle a été condamnée par le
tribunal administratif à carence et
atteinte à la dignité humaine alors qui
est défaillant madame la députée en
l'occurrence
l'État
le camp a été évacué ce matin que de
temps perdu 48 familles ont été mis à
l'abri que de temps perdu madame donc
qui est défaillant merci je vous
remercie monsieur le ministre madame
rogol
9 condamnations neuf condamnations par
la Cour européenne des droits de l'homme
c'est ce qui a eu la France sous
Emmanuel Macron pour son inaction face à
ses problèmes de logement conditions
d'existence inhumaine et dégradante de
demandeurs d'asile dans la rue privée de
moyens de licence c'est ça votre réalité
et c'est pour ça que vous serez condamné
beaucoup monsieur le ministre
[Applaudissements]
madame la députée sur l'action de
gouvernement et de la première ministre
nous avons maintenu les places
d'hébergement d'urgence à un niveau
jamais atteint à plus de 200000 places
19000 places d'hébergement d'urgence en
dans le Haut-Rhin et je vais vous
assurer que nous agissons que nous
agissons tous les jours et bien bien sûr
merci je vous remercie monsieur le
ministre la parole est à Madame catiana
le Vavasseur pour le groupe
rassemblement national
merci madame la Présidente
ma question s'adresse à Madame la
Ministre de la
merci madame la Présidente ma question
s'adresse à madame la ministre de la
transition énergétique
depuis plusieurs mois le thème de la
housse des énergies c'est imposer au
sein de cette hémicycle et une fois
encore je me dois dire revenir pourquoi
car la situation ne s'améliore pas ce
week-end encore je me faisais
interpeller dans les rues du Neubourg
dans l'heure par des chefs d'entreprise
sur les difficultés qui sont les leurs à
l'approche de Noël le boulanger
contraint de stopper un fourneau sur
deux le poissonnier de réduire son étale
les bouchers vous les avez entendu la
semaine dernière
avez-vous d'ailleurs pu apporter une
réponse satisfaisante à leur
revendication
beaucoup de gens attendent des mesures
de protection beaucoup n'en bénéficient
pas ainsi alors que la période des fêtes
normalement synonyme de hausse des
ventes et d'embauche de personnel
approche à grands pas ces hommes et ses
femmes qui font vivre nos territoires
grâce à leur commerce de proximité se
voient contraint de revoir leur calcul
prévisionnel à la baisse
de nombreux gérants m'ont ainsi confié
qui leur sera impossible d'engager de
nouvelles recrues comme c'est le cas
généralement durant cette période de
l'année mais pire encore certains
envisagent de mettre une partie de leur
salarié en activité partielle la hausse
des coûts de l'électricité obligent les
gérants de PME et TPE à réduire leur
activité ceux qui entraînent des pertes
de chiffre d'affaires et donc des
conséquences sur les employés
alors vous qui avez des grands projets
pour l'emploi en France vous qui voulez
retarder l'âge de départ à la retraite
vous qui voulez diminuer la durée
d'indemnisation de l'assurance chômage
quelles sont vos propositions concernant
cette énième problématique touchant les
commerçants celle de l'emploi et de la
préservation en cette période charnière
de l'année en pleine crise d'énergie
merci je vous remercie
la parole est à Madame olive da Grégoire
ministre délégué chargé des petites et
moyennes entreprises du commerce de
l'artisanat et du tourisme
madame la députée Levavasseur merci pour
vos questions vos questions qui sont
nombreuses ça tombe bien celle des
commerçants des artisans sont nombreuses
aussi vous m'avez posé des questions
précises je vais donc pas lire mon
papier je vais répondre précisément
est-ce que j'ai reçu les bouchers depuis
bientôt 3 mois oui madame est-ce que
nous avons regardé avec précision leur
facture pour regarder ce qu'il en est et
voir la réalité des faits c'est à dire
qu'entre l'augmentation du mégawater et
l'augmentation finale de la facture il y
a parfois des différences et que ces
factures sont complexes compliquées à
comprendre je vous le dis parce que
moi-même j'ai parfois des difficultés
oui c'est compliqué et oui mais je vous
prends chacune et chacun au défi de lire
avec dextérité l'ensemble de ces
factures c'est le propre du fer plutôt
que du parler les preuves de l'action et
c'est compliqué ces augmentations de
facture qu'est-ce qu'on voit madame on
voit aujourd'hui des acteurs des des
artisans qui premièrement sont en partie
aidés impôts.gouv.fr les aides
commencent à être distribués et on voit
des commerçants on voit des commerçants
qui aujourd'hui sont au cœur des
augmentations de l'emploi il vous a pas
été échappé puisque vous questionnez sur
l'emploi que nous avons continué à avoir
des bons chiffres que nous avons un
chômage qui continue à baisser que nos
PME sont au cœur des recrutements il y a
effectivement beaucoup de
questionsnements sur 2023 vous m'avez
parlé des bouchers oui madame je les ai
reçus est-ce qu'on va trouver des
solutions oui madame est-ce que je les
reçois un par un oui et c'est bien
normal vous devriez en faire de même ça
vous permettrait d'éviter de dire
parfois des erreurs parce qu'ils ont du
sang-froid et qu'on va le passer
ensemble cet hiver il recrute c'est
compliqué et pour terminer sur
l'assurance chômage madame ils n'ont
qu'un mot merci de légiférer merci
d'être courageux merci de faire ce que
nous attendons c'est-à-dire enfin de
condamner les abandons de poste enfin
d'encourager les gens à reprendre du
boulot de nous amener de la main
d'oeuvre parce que nous on veut
embaucher voilà ce qu'ils disent et
c'est ce que nous essayons de faire ici
au sein du gouvernement merci beaucoup
madame la ministre la parole est à
Monsieur Philippe fait pour le groupe
Renaissance
sec ministre délégué des personnes
handicapées ce samedi 3 décembre nous
avons célébré la journée internationale
des personnes handicapées une journée
créée en 1992 donc 30 ans pour
promouvoir la compréhension des
questions de handicap et mobiliser le
soutien pour la dignité le droit et le
bien-être des personnes atteintes pour
autant je souhaitais aborder aujourd'hui
deux sujets sur lesquels je suis
particulièrement engagé le handicap et
l'égalité femme homme
à l'occasion de la 26ème édition de la
Semaine européenne pour l'emploi des
personnes handicapées deux enquêtes
sérieuses se sont penchées sur le vécu
des femmes en situation de handicap et
ont mis en exergue une situation
inégalitaire systémique près de 80% des
femmes en situation de handicap déclare
s'occuper des tâches domestiques et
familiales elles-mêmes ce que l'on
appelle la charge mentale est une
problématique qui touche bien des femmes
en France les femmes en situation de
handicap n'échent donc pas à la règle à
cette inégalité systémique il faut
ajouter ce que révèle également ces deux
études des violences subies au sein du
couple une femme handicapée sur quatre
indique avoir déjà subi des violences
conjugales une femme handicapée sur 4 un
chiffre bien supérieur à celui mesuré
auprès de l'ensemble des femmes mais
aussi auprès des hommes handicapés une
femme handicapée sur cinq déclare avoir
déjà été violée une femme handicapée sur
cinq nous sommes au-dessus des chiffres
concernant l'ensemble des femmes une sur
la situation de vulnérabilité physique
psychologique et économique des femmes
en situation de handicap les exposent
donc encore davantage au comportement de
prédation aussi madame la ministre quel
est votre sentiment sur cette
problématique quelle réponse allez-vous
apporter pour mieux protéger les femmes
en situation de handicap et poursuivre
de notre chemin vers une égalité
effective je vous remercie je vous
remercie mon cher collègue la parole est
à Geneviève darrieussec ministre délégué
chargé des personnes handicapées
merci madame la Présidente Mesdames
Messieurs les Députés monsieur le député
Philippe fait
sur le député je vous remercie je vous
remercie de mettre le focus d'abord sur
le handicap et ensuite sur les femmes en
situation de handicap sur l'égalité
homme-femme et sur les violences faites
aux femmes en situation de handicap
alors oui les femmes en situation de
handicap sont deux fois plus victimes
que les autres de violences sexuelles
ces glaçons
oui être une femme et en situation de
handicap c'est la double peine et je ne
peux pas et nous ne pouvons pas
l'accepter
nous travaillons avec Isabelle Rome
pour en plus de l'accès aux droits
communs bien entendu qui concerne ces
femmes et c'est heureux à déployer des
mesures concrètes sur le terrain la
prévention et la détection des violences
demandent nécessairement d'aller vers
ces femmes trop souvent exclues des
parcours traditionnels par exemple un
améliorant le suivi gynécologique des
femmes handicapées un travail de
sensibilisation sur la vie affective et
sexuelle et sur la question du
consentement et de la violence et menée
par exemple aussi la formation des
professionnels des secteurs
médico-social et sanitaires dans le
domaine des luttes contre les violences
savoir détecter les signaux repérer les
situations de violence est absolument
essentielle alors le dispositif Andy
gynéco mis en oeuvre dans trois régions
répond à ces à ces sujets et je souhaite
véritablement qu'il soit généralisé dans
notre pays et puis l'égalité homme-femme
elle passe bien sûr par l'accès à
l'autonomie
la décongélisation de la hache que vous
avez voté cet été va dans ce sens nous
devons veiller à l'accès également les
galaxies à la formation à l'emploi et
par l'autonomie et bien les femmes en
situation de handicap comme toutes les
femmes et bien seront plus plus
indépendantes et plus en sécurité et
enfin vous évoquez le sujet merci
la parole est à madame Andrée thorignat
pour le groupe la France insoumise
madame la présidente madame la Première
ministre en France en théorie la justice
spécifique des mineurs ne fait aucune
référence à la nationalité des enfants
mais force est de constater que les
mineurs non accompagnés ne sont pas
traités de la même manière que les
autres la principale préoccupation des
autorités et de démasquer les faux
mineurs soupçonnés de vouloir indium
profiter de l'aide à l'enfance après un
parcours migratoire traumatisant il
croit arriver au pays des droits de
l'homme mais découvre celui de Kafka il
doit vous prouver leur âge mais on remet
en cause la validité de leur papier
s'ils les ont perdu durant leur pays
périple on les empêche de se mettre en
lien avec leur famille à chaque refus de
minorité ils sont remis à la rue par
l'état français livré à eux-mêmes à Ivry
ils sont 500 dans un campement avec cinq
toilettes et 6 robinets d'eau depuis
vendredi 300 se sont installés devant le
Conseil d'État dans le froid et toujours
en attente d'hébergement 12 ont dû être
évacués par les pompiers
malgré les demandes des élus locaux sans
proposer de solutions d'hébergement
pérenne le préfet a donné l'ordre
d'évacuation elle aurait lieu demain au
petit matin de manière inhumaine comme
cette fameuse nuit de novembre 2020
place de la République le Comité des
droits de l'enfant mandaté par l'ONU a
ouvert une enquête sur la prise en
charge des MNA en France madame la
Première ministre prenez l'engagement
solennelle devant la représentation
nationale que votre gouvernement
coopérera de manière transparente dans
le cadre de cette enquête quand
prendrez-vous les mesures qui s'imposent
pour que la France respecte la
Convention internationale des droits de
l'enfant qui édict la présomption de
minorités combien de temps l'état
laissera-t-il ces jeunes à la rue et
dans le froid
je vous remercie madame la députée la
parole est à Madame Charlotte Cobain
1000 secrétaire d'État chargé de
l'enfance
madame la présidente madame la députée
madame messieurs les députés la
principe de présomption de minorité est
totalement respectée dans notre pays
excusez-moi dans notre pays
pardonnez-moi
effectivement le principe selon lequel
un mineur quand il est isolé sur notre
territoire doit être protégé est un
principe formel au nom de la convention
internationale droit de l'enfant et de
nos principes qui font de l'intérêt
supérieur de l'enfant un guide
simplement nous le savons dans ces
dispositifs de protection de l'enfance
des personnes se prétendant mineur dans
la compagnie qui sont majeurs viennent
demander protection vous ne pouvez pas
nier ça madame c'est une réalité nous ne
pouvons concevoir que dans nos
structures des majeurs qu'on doit
côtoient des mineurs c'est une question
de protection des mineurs notre
dispositif est très clair ce sont les
départements qui sont en charge de
l'évaluation de la minorité et ce n'est
pas le dispositif migratoire ce sont
donc de la responsabilité des justement
et le cas échéant des juges des enfants
s'ils sont eux-mêmes saisis donc le
principe de minorité est respecté les
droits fondamentaux des enfants sont
respectés ils sont protégés pour autant
que ce soit des enfants et pas des
majeurs
[Applaudissements]
je vous remercie madame la ministre
madame thorignat en fait madame la
ministre vous estivez faudra-t-il
attendre des morts pour que vous
réagissiez
madame la ministre
c'est effectivement trop facile de faire
ce type d'accusation 18000 mineurs sont
hébergés aujourd'hui par les
départements de France chaque année ce
qui fait évidemment et non enfin ça fait
presque 100 000 mineurs qui sont
accueillis on a même pris des
dispositions pour les protéger jusqu'à
21 ans les mineurs non accompagnés sont
protégés en France et nous leur assurons
la protection internationale qui est due
par nos conventions
je vous remercie madame la ministre la
parole est à Monsieur Jean-Charles
Larsonneur pour le groupe horizon merci
madame la Présidente ma question
s'adresse au ministre de la Santé nous
sommes en ce début d'hiver confronté une
triple épidémie de covid de grippe et de
bronchiolite sans précédent depuis 10
ans pour cette dernière une triple
épidémique qui touche tous les Français
qui met sous forte tension à notre
système de santé et qui éprouve une
nouvelle fois nos soignants un plan
blanc national en réponse à l'épidémie
de bronchiolite a été déclenché le 10
novembre dernier et décliné dans de
nombreux établissements et territoires
singulièrement dans l'ouest de la France
comme en Ille-et-Vilaine
tous nous souhaitons passer les fêtes de
fin d'année de manière sûre sereine en
protégeant nos proches nos anciens et
les plus fragiles autour de nous nous
avons été unanimement solidaire autour
de nos soignants depuis le début de la
pandémie covid nous n'avons pas changé
monsieur le ministre et je crois que
nous portons une responsabilité
collective pour nous protéger et
soulager nos soignants auxquels je veux
rendre ici un hommage appuyé
il n'est pas inutile de rappeler d'abord
que la vaccination est efficace pour se
prévenir des formes graves de covid
comme de grippe mais ma question
monsieur le ministre porte sur les
gestes barrières et singulièrement sur
le port du masque c'est un geste simple
comme le lavage de main qui nous protège
qui protège les autres et réduit
drastiquement les risques de
transmission un geste simple mais que
nous sommes trop nombreux à te laisser
bien souvent parce que nous avons perdu
le réflexe d'avoir un masque à portée de
main
ne peut-on sensibiliser davantage à
travers des campagnes et la télévision à
la radio dans les médias sur l'utilité
de porter le masque vous l'avez dit
monsieur le ministre vous n'aurez pas la
main tremblante s'il vous faut prendre
vos responsabilités alors n'est-il pas
temps de rendre obligatoire le port du
masque dans les transports en commun au
travail ou dans les centres commerciaux
alors où les familles françaises font
leurs courses de Noël
je vous remercie la parole est à
François Braun ministre de la santé et
de la prévention
madame la Présidente Mesdames et
Messieurs les Députés monsieur le député
d'arseneur vous avez raison la covid 19
continue à circuler elle continue à tuer
tous les jours chaque jour des personnes
fragiles ou non dans notre pays le taux
d'incidence au cours de ces derniers
jours a augmenté de 40% ceux qui
montrent cette augmentation de
circulation du virus vous l'avez rappelé
cette circulation arrive dans des
circonstances nouvelles et particulières
nouvelle parce que il y a une triple
épidémie actuellement une équipe de
bronchiolite et nous en sommes pas
encore au sommet de cette épidémie une
épidémie de grippe qui arrive par
l'Ouest du pays qui concerne maintenant
en face pré épidémique plus de la moitié
de l'ensemble du territoire national et
cette reprise de l'épidémie covid le
tout arrivant sur un système de santé en
difficulté à bout de souffle je l'ai
déjà dit donc ce qui ne facilite pas
loin de là des choses
la situation actuelle est d'autant plus
insupportable que nous avons les moyens
de nous protéger et de nous protéger les
Français ces moyens c'est d'abord vous
l'avez dit la vaccination la vaccination
reste notre arme de protection massive
face au virus au virus au pluriel en
particulier la grippe et le covid cette
vaccination est insuffisamment
développée de l'ordre de 20% pour les
plus de 80 ans 80% pour les 60 80 ans
c'est très en deux ça de ce que nous
avons fait dans les campagnes
précédentes quant à la vaccination
contre la grippe elle est là aussi
inférieure à l'année dernière or ce sont
ces personnes qui sont les plus fragiles
qu'il faut protéger mais je tiens aussi
à rappeler ici pour être parfaitement
clair que toute personne qui souhaite se
faire vacciner peut se faire vacciner il
est important que ce soit les plus
fragiles qui soient vaccinés en premier
mais d'autres personnes et en
particulier leur entourage doit
également se faire vacciner pour les
protéger
en ce qui concerne au-delà de la
vaccination les gestes barrières les
gestes barrières le lavage de mains le
port de masse sont des gestes qui
protègent en plus de ces 3 virus et de
ces trois épidémies ils sont essentiels
dans tous les lieux où il y a de la
promiscuité j'invite les Français à
porter le masque de façon systématique
pour être se protéger être solidaire des
soignants je vous remercie je vous
remercie
la parole est à Monsieur Marcelin Nadaud
pour le groupe cause démocrate et
républicaine merci
merci madame la Présidente ma question
s'adresse à monsieur le garde des sceaux
ministre de la justice monsieur le
ministre la pollution durable par le
chlore des cônes en Guadeloupe et à
Martinique constitue selon les termes
même du plan chords 4 gouvernement et je
cite par son ampleur il sa persistance
un enjeu sanitaire environnemental
agricole économique et sociales pour les
Antilles or en plus de ces aspects
énoncés force est de constater qu'il
s'agit aussi et désormais de scandale
judiciaire en effet le 24 novembre
dernier après 16 années de bataille
juridique le parquet de Paris a
préconisé un non-lieu dans l'affaire du
crime nommé chlordécone dans ce dossier
le ministère public donc le gouvernement
préconise le silence et l'impunité
découvert de non-lieu la boucle est donc
bouclée la justice ne peut condamner
l'État et l'État demande à la justice
d'absoudre les divers responsables de ce
crime d'empoisonnement de ce jeu de
couverture réciproque se dégage en force
sentiment de mépris à l'égard des
peuples empoisonnés de Martinique et de
Guadeloupe dont les populations selon
santé publique France serait contaminé à
plus de 90% ici il n'y a même pas de
responsable non coupable comme dans
l'affaire du sang contaminé alors que
près d'un demi million de personnes
demeure empoisonnées pour vous ça semble
ne pas être grave il est vrai qu'on est
aux Antilles aux Antilles où on a
souvent le sentiment d'être encore
autant des colonies alors monsieur le
ministre monsieur le ministre ma
question est simple peut-on se
satisfaire d'une responsabilité morale
où on empoisonnement de cette ampleur
sans que la justice passe sans merci
beaucoup monsieur le député la parole
est à Jean-François caraco ministre
délégué chargé des Outre-mer
bien précis d'abord ce dont nous parlons
il s'agit pas d'une décision de justice
définitive mais du réquisitoire du
procureur de la République
de toutes les façons
de toutes les façons ce gouvernement ne
commence pas les positions de la justice
et nous respectons l'indépendance de la
justice notamment dans les Antilles
par contre
on peut y aller
je peux y aller merci
par contre il m'appartiendra plus que le
Président de la République et le premier
à avoir reconnu la responsabilité de
l'État dans la pollution du chlore des
cônes sous son impulsion des avancées
fortes ont été obtenus reconnaissance du
cancer de la prostate comme maladie
professionnelle ouvrant droit à
indemnisation analyse gratuite de taux
de chlore des cotes dans le sang pour
toute la population
analyse gratuit des sols pour les
agriculteurs et les particuliers grâce
aux travaux de recherche capacité à
réduire par deux la teneurs de chlore
des cônes dans le sens six mois
accompagnement des agriculteurs et des
particuliers pour cultiver des produits
sains y compris sur les terres
contaminées tout ceci est en cours a été
présenté lors d'une réunion que j'ai
présidée avec ma collègue firmait le
Bodo le 4 novembre
mais il fallait y être
le colloque scientifique il est
rencontre clandécone qui se déroulent
cette semaine la semaine prochaine en
Guadeloupe et en Martinique sur
l'occasion de nouveaux échanges
constructifs sur le corps
sur ce sujet comme tant d'autres je vous
en prie arrêtons les polémiques
inutiles avant son au profit des
populations antillaises et je sais pour
voir compter sur vous quand vous quand
vous savez le faire
je vous remercie monsieur le ministre la
parole est à Madame marine un molette
pour le groupe rassemblement national
je vous remercie madame la Présidente ma
question s'adresse à Monsieur Ndiaye
monsieur le ministre je suis aujourd'hui
la porte-parole d'une professeure du
lycée de Montauban dans le
Tarn-et-Garonne mon département cette
professeur a tenté avec ses collègues de
faire respecter la loi sur la laïcité
face à des élèves portant des abeilles
et des voiles aussi à certains cours
victimes depuis de menaces je vous
adresse ces quelques lignes extraites
d'une lettre
aujourd'hui je cite aujourd'hui l'école
républicaine mène la bataille la plus
cruciale de son histoire face à l'hydre
islamiste des enseignants de ce pays
sont seuls lâché par la hiérarchie et
pire que tout méprisé par ceux la même
qui fournissent des circulaires et des
protocoles leur expliquant comment tenir
la tranchée quand eux désertent le champ
de bataille
acceptez tolérer la multiplication des
particularismes culturels comme
cultuelles dénatures l'esprit de la
laïcité car l'école devient aujourd'hui
un espace de ségrégation pour ceux qui
appliquent le droit à la ressemblance
ces mots monsieur le ministre je l'ai
fait bien après les paroles il est grand
temps de passer rosat cette professeur a
subi des pressions elle est désespérée
aujourd'hui au point d'avoir perdu la
vocation
elle est d'ailleurs en arrêt maladie son
cas n'est malheureusement pas isolé
l'offensive du communautarisme islamisme
c'est considérablement accéléré depuis
la rentrée de septembre et ça le
monsieur le ministre vous le savez
qu'attendez-vous pour agir ne me
répondez pas qu'il faut porter plainte
car porter plainte n'a pas évité à
Monsieur Samuel Paty
la mort combien de Samuel Paty
faudra-t-il pour que vous preniez la
mesure de notre situation
monsieur le ministre ma question est
simple quand visageez-vous pour faire
respecter la laïcité dans nos écoles et
assurer la protection fonctionnelle des
agents publics qui tentent de la défense
je vous remercie la parole est à
Monsieur pas Penda une ministre de
l'éducation nationale et de la jeunesse
merci madame la Présidente Mesdames et
Messieurs les Députés madame la député
hamlé les chiffres de signalement des
atteintes à la laïcité pour le mois de
novembre ne sont pas encore tout à fait
consolidés mais je peux vous indiquer
que les premiers éléments marquent une
baisse extrêmement conséquente je tiens
à rappeler également que face à
l'augmentation des chiffres d'atteinte à
laïcité au mois d'octobre j'ai mis en
place un plan laïcité reposant sur
quatre axes d'abord la sanction
systématique et de manière graduée des
comportements répréhensibles des élèves
concernés ensuite la protection et le
soutien au personnel y compris les
dépôts de plainte mais également la
protection fonctionnelle enfin
l'appui aux actions des chefs
d'établissement et le renforcement de la
formation des personnels ce sont des
mesures concrètes qui sont basées sur un
triptyque le la sanction la protection
si nécessaire c'est une méthode qui a
prouvé son efficacité d'ailleurs dans le
lycée que vous citez le lycée Bourdel de
Montauban alors qu'une vingtaine
d'élèves venaient en Aya au début de
l'année scolaire grâce au dialogue mais
aussi au sanction lorsque le dialogue
avec les élèves et les familles n'a pas
suffi il n'y a plus que deux situations
qui sont en voie de résolution ma
méthode je le redis c'est l'application
stricte de la loi de 2004 c'est le fait
de trouver les voies et moyens pour
maintenir les élèves dans la République
c'est le rôle de l'école c'est le rôle
du ministère de l'Éducation nationale je
vous remercie monsieur le ministre
madame Hamlin
vous venez de le dire monsieur le
ministre des problèmes perdus ce n'est
pas suffisant il faut prendre des
mesures supplémentaires vous serez jugé
sur vos résultats monsieur le ministre
je vous remercie monsieur le ministre
je viens de vous indiquer madame la
députée que l'on observe une baisse
significative des atteintes à la laïcité
pour le mois de novembre en particulier
pour ceux qui concerne le port de
vêtements et de signes à intention
religieuse mais voyez-vous madame la
députée la laïcité c'est une liberté
c'est l'émancipation par le savoir elle
n'est pas faite pour des effets de
manches politiciens je vous remercie
monsieur le ministre
la parole est à Monsieur Raphaël chez
l'unberger pour le groupe les
républicains
merci madame la présidente madame la
Première ministre vous soumettez au
Parlement de façon successive des textes
sur l'énergie qui ne font toujours que
des dispositifs d'ajustements sans
jamais donner réellement de vision
d'ensemble sans jamais avoir réellement
fixé un cap clair plus que des doutes
aujourd'hui nous avons des craintes il y
a deux semaines lors de votre
déclaration sur la politique énergétique
de la France vous avez indiqué
travailler à identifier les réacteurs
nucléaires qui seront fermés à l'âge de
50 ans pour tenir dans les décennies qui
viennent il nous faudra pourtant tout
mettre en oeuvre pour porter notre parc
nucléaire au-delà de 60 ans les annonces
que vous avez formulées craindre que
vous n'ayez pas changé de cap par
rapport à la programmation plus réelle
de l'énergie que vous avez fait voter
lorsque vous étiez ministre de
l'écologie et qui prévoyait la réduction
à 50% de la part du nucléaire dans notre
mix électrique madame la Première
ministre pouvez-vous nous confirmer que
vous avez bien pris en compte le
discours de Belfort du candidat Macron
changer d'avis par rapport à 2019
je vous remercie
la parole est à Madame Agnès panier
renacher ministre de la transition
énergétique
merci madame la Présidente Mesdames et
Messieurs les Députés monsieur le député
chez l'homme berger la vision de notre
sur notre politique énergétique vous la
connaissez à la clairement été exprimée
lors d'un débat qui a été conduit ici
par la première ministre elle a
également clairement été exprimée vous
l'avez souligné dans le discours de
Belfort du président de la République le
8 février dernier elle repose sur un
triptyque première élément sobriété
efficacité énergétique il s'agit de
diminuer notre consommation d'énergie
finale c'est un objectif que nous
assigne notamment les experts
climatiques 40% de réduction c'est le
scénario RTE deuxième objectif
développer massivement les énergies
renouvelables parce que ce sont celles
dont nous pouvons avoir besoin dans les
années qui viennent parce qu'elles
peuvent être rapidement développées
parce qu'elles sont bas carbone parce
qu'elles sont compétitives en prix et
vont permettre de baisser le prix que
paye les Français et les entreprises sur
notre territoire français troisième
objectif
relancer la filière nucléaire et je
crois qu'il n'y a aucune ambiguïté sur
ce sujet là vous le savez le débat
concernant la mise en place des deux
premières réacteurs à panli et lancer
vous le savez également nous travaillons
avec EDF et le nouveau patron de DF afin
qu'il anticipe d'ores et déjà non
seulement la mise en œuvre de mesure
d'excellence opérationnelles sur le park
existant pour augmenter la production
d'électricité et réduire le délai des
maintenances opérationnelles et nous
avons trois à quatre semaines que nous
pouvons gagner dans les trois années qui
viennent sur ces arrêts mais également
pour allonger le plus possible et en
sécurité l'exploitation des 56 réacteurs
aujourd'hui en fonctionnement le plus
possible et en sécurité les deux
éléments comptent et c'est bien ce que
la première ministre vous a indiqué lors
du débat sur la politique énergétique et
le troisième construire de nouveaux
réacteurs ce sera en tout cas notre
proposition lors du débat que vous aurez
l'occasion de vous sur la loi énergie
climat qui sera examinée l'année
prochaine je ne crois donc il y a pas
long d'une ambiguïté sur notre objectif
Monsieur selenberger Merci
mais la présente Madame la Ministre
d'abord je regrette toujours que quand
on parle du mix énergétique il est
difficile de discuter avec la Ministre
chargée l'énergie pourtant dessaisie de
près de 40% du mix énergétique français
dans l'attribution de ses compétences
pour le reste vous n'avez pas levé le
flou sur la question de du parc
nucléaire et de l'âge auquel vous
entendez le fermer madame la ministre la
première ministre lors du débat a fait
entendre que certains de nos réacteurs
pourraient être fermés à 50 ans alors
que nous devons tout faire pour les
faire monter au moins au moins à 60 ans
pour le reste la réalité madame la
ministre de l'énergie c'est
qu'aujourd'hui au moment où nous avons
absolument besoin d'électricité les
éoliennes tous les jours ces derniers
temps alors qu'il fait froid elle tourne
à hauteur de 2% environ c'est à dire
qu'elle ne produisent quasiment rien
alors que c'est le moment où nous avons
besoin d'électricité pour chauffer et
pour éclairer les Français
la parole est à Madame Nicole lepet pour
le groupe Renaissance merci madame la
Présidente de ma question s'adresse à
Madame la Ministre de l'Europe et des
Affaires étrangères hier le lundi 5
décembre est entré en vigueur l'embargo
sur le pétrole russe décidé par les pays
membres de l'Union européenne cette
sanction inédite couplée à la décision
des États européens du G7 et de
l'Australie
de plafonner le prix du baril de pétrole
russe doit permettre de porter un coup
décisif à l'effort de guerre russe cette
décision affectera encore plus durement
les revenus de la Russie tout en
stabilisant les prix de l'énergie ce qui
profitera à tous les états étant
confrontés à des prix du pétrole élevés
ce plafond trouve le juste équilibre et
envoie un signal nécessaire
il est en effet intolérable que les
responsables de ce conflit soient
également des profiteurs de guerre alors
que la semaine dernière notre majorité a
voté d'une seule voix pour une
résolution en soutien l'Ukraine et
condamnant la création russe
l'application de cette sanction témoigne
aussi que nous nous tenons comme depuis
le 1er jour aux côtés de l'Ukraine dans
la souveraineté est bafouée
l'application d'une telle mesure nous en
avons tous conscience n'est pas sans
représenter un défi toutefois l'Union
européenne a déjà prouvé sa
détermination à renforcer son
indépendance énergétique notamment
vis-à-vis des énergies fossiles russes
tout en maintenant son ambition
écologique comme le démontre la mise en
action du plan ripower œil aussi madame
la ministre comment évaluez-vous
l'impact corromper mesure sur le pouvoir
de nuisances de la Russie et quel autre
sanction peuvent être envisagées en
concertation avec nos alliés afin
d'empêcher la Russie d'engranger des
revenus nécessaires à son effort de
guerre je vous remercie
je vous remercie ma chère collègue la
parole est à Madame Catherine Colonna
ministre de l'Europe et des Affaires
étrangères
merci madame la Présidente Mesdames et
Messieurs les Députés mesdames la
députée merci merci de me permettre de
revenir sur cet accord qui a été trouvé
entre-européen mais aussi avec nos
partenaires du G7 plus l'Australie sur
le plafonnement des prix du pétrole
russe un plafonnement qui vient
compléter l'arsenal de sanction déjà
déployée en réaction à l'agression russe
en Ukraine c'est une mesure utile car
elle contribuera à réduire fortement la
capacité de la Russie à mener sa guerre
à financer sa guerre en diminuant les
revenus tirés du pétrole c'est une
mesure qui démontre aussi une nouvelle
fois la qualité de la coordination menée
au sein du G7 pour sanctionner l'effort
de Garrus sanctionner les profiteurs de
guerre comme vous l'avez dit madame la
députée pour la suite puisque c'est
aussi votre question l'Union européenne
continue de travailler à de nouvelles
mesures après déjà 8 paquets de
sanctions qui pèsent sur
le régime russe plusieurs options
supplémentaires sont à l'étude notamment
la restriction d'exportation dans les
domaines technologiques et bancaires et
des services ainsi que de nouvelles
désignations individuelles de
responsable politique militaire et
économique russe qui soutiennent la
guerre et nous avons aussi sanctionné
madame la députée et les responsables
impliqués dans des transferts de drones
iraniens utilisés par la Russie en
Ukraine ainsi que les biélorusses qui
aident la Russie dans sa guerre
d’agression nous continuerons à le faire
tout ceci tout ceci sera à l'ordre du
jour du prochain conseil à faire
générale à Bruxelles lundi prochain donc
rendez-vous lundi 12 décembre je vous
remercie je vous remercie madame la
ministre la parole est à Monsieur Arnaud
Le Gall pour le groupe la France
insoumise
ma question s'adresse à Monsieur le
Ministre de la souveraineté industrielle
monsieur le ministre la semaine dernière
Emmanuel Macron est allé se plaindre à
jobiden de l'inseum édition Act plan de
370 milliards de dollars de soutien
l'économie des États-Unis qui distortent
la concurrence avec l'Europe en retour
flatterie et vagues promesses
l'humiliation la France et l'Europe sont
hors jeu loin notre nez plus de
solidarité occidentale la guerre en
Ukraine radicalisent la compétition
comme le montre le prix exorbitant
auquel les États-Unis nous vendent gaz
et pétrole les États-Unis sont un grand
pays aux côtés duquel nous avons des
défis communs à relever pour autant il
ne considère pas l'espace
transatlantique comme exemple de
compétition dans le capitalisme
globalisé la concurrence généralisée la
règle et elle n'est jamais livrée non
faussée
a raison de conditionner les aides
publiques à la création d'emplois locaux
de relocaliser les productions pour
réduire la vulnérabilité de son pays de
consacrer 80 milliards au renforcement
de la lutte contre l'évasion et la
fraude fiscale votre politique
néolibérale est libre et échangiste sans
voir ringardiser avec ses 140 milliards
d'aide annuelles aux entreprises sans
contrepartie son plan de relance
européen qui n'aura fait que gaver la
finance son refus de tout
protectionnisme son obsession des
équilibres budgétaires alors même que
cela gonfle la dette contre laquelle
vous prétendez lutter il est urgent de
changer et non de demander à Biden de le
faire notre avenir industriel l'emploi
notre indépendance énergétique sanitaire
stratégique sont en jeu nous ne devons
être dépendants ni des États-Unis ni de
la Russie ni de la Chine ni de quiconque
quand on travaillerez-vous à la mise en
place d'un protectionnisme écologique et
social européen et seriez-vous prêt à
désobéir et autres européens en le
faisant en France n'attendons pas une
illusoire autorisation de la commission
ou de l'Allemagne l'avenir du peuple
français est en jeu
merci mon cher collègue la parole est à
Monsieur Roland Lescure ministre délégué
chargé de l'Industrie
si madame la Présidente Mesdames et
Messieurs les Députés monsieur le député
Le Gal cette visite du président de la
République à Washington la semaine
dernière est une visite historique
exceptionnelle d'abord parce que c'est
la deuxième fois qui a président
l'exercice français se rend une visite
d'État aux États-Unis ensuite parce que
c'était la première du président Joe
Biden et enfin et surtout parce qu'elle
a permis peut-être à votre désagrément
d'affirmer une fois encore une amitié
forte solide historique et inscrite dans
le passé et dans l'avenir de de donation
des États-Unis d'Amérique et de la
France elle a permis aussi et vous le
savez d'avoir un échange franc honnête
et transparent sur les enjeux de la
compétition internationale du soutien de
l'industrie française européenne et
américaine par les États respectifs
américains et français elle a enfin
permis d'affirmer que la compétition
juste et loyale entre deux amis elle
était à l'ordre du jour le président Joe
Biden l'affirmé il a eu l'occasion de
réaliser combien lira avait pu inquiéter
les Européens il a pu avoir l'occasion
d'affirmer à nouveau que lira ne voyait
en aucun cas de ce voyant aucun cas
comme une menace pour l'industrie
européenne mais comme une réponse réelle
et ambitieuse à des mesures de
protection d'autres pays certains
d'ailleurs que vous avez tendance
souvent à soutenir enfin vous le savez
le président de la République est Bruno
Le Maire en nous l'occasion de la fermer
notre politique de soutien à l'industrie
européenne elle va se poursuivre dans
une logique de décarbonation avec vous
en êtes heureux j'espère de la
conditionnalité puisque les 54 milliards
du plan France 2030 qui accompagne
l'industrie sur la voie de carbonations
vous le savez sont conditionnés à des
efforts réels je vous remercie monsieur
le député
je vous remercie monsieur le ministre
monsieur Le Gall
on n'a rien obtenu vous irez raconter ça
sur l'amitié franco-américaine quand les
premières délocalisations vers les
États-Unis auront lieu
le ministre
vous avez 15 secondes monsieur le
ministre
15 secondes pour vous rappeler que la
planète sur laquelle nous vivons est une
planète dans lequel la réalité
économique s'imposa tous dans laquelle
l'amitié historique est essentielle et
dans lequel le partenariat
franco-américain a encore de beaux jours
devant lui ne vous en déplaise je vous
remercie monsieur le ministre la parole
est à Monsieur Pierre Cordier pour les
républicains
merci madame la présidente madame la
Première ministre nous connaissions la
France des Lumières avec vous nous
aurons la France des bougies
la circulaire que vous avez adressée au
préfet pour qu'il se prépare à
d'éventuelles coupures programmées de
l'électricité scandalise nos concitoyens
ces coupures renommés pudiquement
délestage concernerait 60% des Français
sans faire la distinction entre des
domiciles vides et des logements de
personnes
âgées dépendantes ou de famille avec des
enfants en bas âge les trains métro ou
tramway pourront être interrompus
empêchant nos concitoyens d'aller au
travail des écoles fermées pour ne pas
risquer de se retrouver sans chauffage
ni lumière ni à l'arme obligeant les
parents à rester chez eux comment notre
pays peut-il se retrouver dans cette
situation et pourtant nous pensions
avoir tout vu avec votre gestion
calamiteuse de la crise covid j'ai
rencontré des citoyens en colère dans
mon département des Ardennes ce week-end
parce que les télés alarmes étaient les
téléphones fixes ne fonctionneront plus
parce que sans leur appareil médicaux
connectés les personnes hospitalisées à
domicile seront en danger en effet le
préfet ne pourra pas isoler un logement
dans une zone coupée concrètement
avez-vous pensé aux milliers de
personnes sous assistance respiratoires
aux porteur d'un cœur artificiel qui
doivent recharger leur batterie à nos
concitoyens branchés à des pousses
seringues qui ne peuvent se passer
d'électricité sans compter les dialysés
à domicile nos concitoyens doivent-ils
investir dans des groupes électrogènes
en urgence madame la Première ministre
la guerre en Ukraine à Bondo ce sont en
réalité dix années 10 années de gestion
Hollande Macron qui sont la cause de
cette situation inacceptable dans un
pays comme le nôtre madame la Première
ministre assumez vos erreurs et trouver
des solutions concrètes sans mettre nos
concitoyens les plus fragiles en danger
merci monsieur le député
la parole est à Madame Agnès panière une
haché ministre de la transition
énergétique
merci madame la Présidente Mesdames et
Messieurs les Députés monsieur le député
Cordier bien au contraire les Français
sont rassurés de savoir que le
gouvernement est au travail pour
préparer le passage de l'hiver dans les
meilleures conditions et les Français
ont bien vu que sur le sujet du gaz
alors même que le principal fournisseur
de l'Europe était manquant avec 40% d'un
fourniture de gaz en Europe en dépit de
cette situation nous sommes aujourd'hui
en capacité de passer cet hiver
sereinement parce que nos stocks sont
remplis parce que nous avons anticipé au
niveau national et au niveau européen et
les Français savent que gouverner ses
prévoir prévoir c'est préparer des plans
dans les situations les plus extrêmes
lorsqu'on prépare un plan blanc
lorsqu'on prépare un plan rouge on ne le
fait pas en espérant qu'un avion va
s'écraser ou qu'un accident arrive on le
fait pour anticiper le pire des
scénarios et c'est ce que nous faisons
mais dans le même temps nous sommes à la
pour que ces délestages n'arrivent pas
et je vous reviens je vous renvoie sur
les prévisions de RTE qui l'ont dit très
clairement ces scénarios extrêmes il
intervient qu'en ultime recourt pour
protéger notre système énergétique dans
l'attente avec le plan sobriété nous
sommes aujourd'hui à une baisse de
consommation d'électricité de 7% en deux
mois corriger des variables saisonnières
et nous allons continuer à travailler
avec les grandes entreprises avec les
administrations en renforçant nos
interconnexions européennes européennes
pour faire en sorte qu'effectivement
nous évitions les délaissages alors
plutôt que d'affoler les Français soyez
à nos côtés pour travailler et faire en
sorte que cet hiver se passe dans les
meilleures conditions ce serait la
preuve de votre responsabilité votez le
projet sur les énergies renouvelables ce
serait également la preuve de votre
responsabilité je vous remercie madame
la ministre la parole est à Monsieur
Jean-Pierre cubertaffond pour le groupe
démocrate merci madame la Présidente mes
chers collègues ma question s'adresse à
Madame la Ministre délégué des
collectivités territoriales et de la
ruralité
l'ambition d'améliorer la qualité de vie
dans les petites communes et les
territoires ruraux a conduit au
déploiement du programme petite ville de
demain lancer par le gouvernement en
2021 et animé par l'Agence nationale de
la cohésion des territoires il regroupe
1640 communes de moins de 20000
habitants pour renforcer les moyens des
élus tout au long de leur mandat les
élus ont encouragé de nombreuses actions
et de première des premières
concretsisations sont visibles madame la
ministre la mise en place des stratégies
de territoires est en voie d'achèvement
et la priorité doit aujourd'hui être
donnée à la recherche du plus grand
impact possible sur laquelle était de
vie des habitants ainsi que sur la
transition écologique pourriez-vous en
ce sens nous indiquer les différents
axes de développement du programme
attendu en 2023 enfin la qualité de vie
des habitants de ces petites villes
repose également aujourd'hui sur un
aspect d'une importance capitale et
grandissante la dans ce but que la
gendarmerie nationale et la police
nationale ont mis en place des
stratégies locales qui favorisent le
contact entre les forces les élus et la
population c'est dans cet esprit que les
brigades de gendarmerie les groupes de
police agissent quotidiennement au
service de la sécurité de tous en lien3
avec les services de l'État le maire
doit en sa responsabilité s'assurer du
bon ordre de la sécurité de la sûreté et
de la salubrité publique mais aussi de
la prévention de la délinquance je me
permettrai donc une seconde question
madame la ministre à savoir si vous
pourriez nous indiquer les différentes
dispositions et mesures choisies afin de
permettre aux maires d'assurer ses
fonctions essentielles à la vie de leurs
citoyens
je vous remercie la parole est à Madame
Dominique Faure ministre délégué chargé
des collectivités territoriales et de la
ruralité
merci madame la Présidente de Mesdames
et Messieurs les Députés monsieur le
député cubertaffond je vous remercie de
mettre en lumière un programme important
porté par l'État au service de nos
territoires le programme petite ville de
demain lancer en octobre 2020 pour
améliorer la qualité de vie des
habitants des centralités de moins de 20
000 habitants et les territoires ruraux
ce programme à d'ores et déjà permis de
nombreuses avancées que vous avez cité
le recrutement de 870 chefs de projet
financé à 75% par l'État si précieux
dans les petites communes pour réfléchir
à des projets territoire mais aussi au
lancement de nombreuses actions dont les
résultats vous l'avez dit sont déjà
visibles aujourd'hui le programme PVD
petite ville de demain c'est 1646
communes et 834 millions d'euros engagés
soit 28% des 3 milliards d'euros
prévisionnels il est vrai que le
programme en est encore à sa phase de
démarrage et je travaille actuellement
sur les leviers permettant de le
renforcer de l'accélérer dans tous les
territoires y compris les plus ruraux
pour tirer pleinement profit des quatre
années restantes le programme arrivant à
échéance en 2026 j'aurais à coeur de
réunir l'ensemble des partis prenantes
afin d'en affirmer les nouvelles
priorités parmi lesquelles figurant en
bonne place l'accompagnement à la
transition écologique et énergétique je
renforcerai aussi le rôle
d'accompagnateur de l'État local qui
devrait favoriser le passage à
l'opérationnel des projets des
collectivités je sais que les attentes
sont fortes en la matière et nous y
répondrons en concertation avec
l'ensemble des partis prenantes je suis
comme vous monsieur le député convaincu
que la qualité de vie et le
développement territorial des petites
villes passent également par la
prévention et la sécurité c'est une
question essentielle pour nos élus
locaux comme pour nos compatriotes c'est
ce que nous promouvons avec les contrats
de sécurité dans lesquelles dans
lesquels se sont engagés à ce jour 135
communes qui décline au niveau local une
stratégie sur mesure entre l'État et la
commune il me semble important de
souligner notre ambition tant pour
petite ville de demain qu'en matière
l'accompagnement des communes dans leur
stratégie de sécurité ces deux volets de
notre action constituant de parfaits
exemples de la méthode de travail
partenariale cher au gouvernement qui va
guider mon action dans les semaines et
mois à venir merci beaucoup madame la
ministre la parole est à Madame anapié
pour le groupe socialiste merci Madame
la question s'adresse à monsieur le
ministre de l'éducation nationale et de
la Genèse je veux vous rassurer il n'y a
aucun risque de coupure d'électricité
parce que quand il y a des besoins on
s'apprivisionne sur le marché européen
ces mots ont été prononcés par le
Président de la République lui-même en
juin dernier devant l'ensemble de la
presse quotidienne régionale réunie pour
l'occasion comme une mauvaise habitude
qui peine désormais à nous étonner les
faits et décisions prises par
l'exécutive viennent contrarier les
propos tenus quelques mois plus tôt par
ce même exécutif cette situation
pourrait prêter assouvir si elle ne
concernait pas directement le quotidien
des Françaises et des Français et là ce
que ces derniers redoutaient et
désormais une réalité des délaissages
pourront avoir lieu au mois de janvier
il y a quelques jours vous confirmiez
monsieur le ministre que les écoles
établissements scolaires seraient
concernés par ses coupures d'électricité
et que ceux-ci seraient amenés à fermer
par demi-journée après les effets
désastreux générés par la fermeture de
ces établissements lors de la crise
sanitaire nous souhaitons aujourd'hui
vous alerter sur la nécessité de les
maintenir ouvert au même titre que les
structures dites critiques catégorie
dont ils devraient naturellement faire
partie l'éducation ne peut pas
continuellement être la variable
d'ajustement des crises successives que
nous traversons c'est fermetures
laissent présager une incidence néfaste
quant à la déstabilisation du rythme
scolaire et sur la santé y compris
mentale des élèves elles auront
également des conséquences économiques
préjudiciables pour les familles
notamment les plus modestes en matière
de garde d'enfant de surcoût des
factures d'énergie ou de restauration en
cas de fermeture des cantines de manière
sous-jacente elles sont aussi une remise
en question du travail des femmes
puisque vous le savez ce sont elles qui
en majorité resteront à domicile pour
garder les enfants les enfants enfin
nous souhaitons également dénoncer la
méthode du gouvernement critiquée par
des syndicats qui n'ont pas été
consultés en amont et qui place la place
de la communauté éducative devant le
fait accompli monsieur le ministre vous
l'aurez compris les inquiétudes et
interrogations sont nombreuses tant pour
les familles que pour les collectivités
locales qui vont devoir mettre en toutes
ces mesures ma question est donc simple
que comptez-vous faire pour apaiser les
tensions engendrées par ces délestages
merci beaucoup ma chère collègue la
parole est à Monsieur Papen Diagne
ministre de l'éducation nationale et de
la jeunesse merci madame la Présidente
Mesdames et Messieurs les Députés madame
la députée pic compte tenu du nombre et
de la densité d'école et d'établissement
scolaire il est impossible de les
préserver a priori d'une éventuelle
coupure d'électricité parce que ça
rendrait tout délaissage impossible il a
donc été décidé une règle nationale si
la coupure est programmée entre 8h et
10h ou bien entre 10h et midi
l'établissement scolaire concerné sera
effectivement fermé le matin ça n'est
pas pour une raison de chauffage c'est
pour une raison de sécurité parce que
les systèmes de sécurité incendie
dépendent de l'électricité pas
d'électricité pas de sécurité voilà la
raison principale je le répète nous ne
sommes absolument pas en dans la même
situation que à l'époque du covid les
coupures d'électricité peuvent ne pas
arriver c'est une éventualité qu'il faut
raisonnablement envisagé sinon de
manière ponctuelle et dans tous les cas
pour une durée limitée à deux heures
nous nous tenons près si jamais une
coupure d'électricité devait se produire
dans des zones spécifiques ça s'appelle
le principe de précaution
si jamais monsieur monsieur le député
madame la député si jamais une coupure
d'électricité devait être nécessaire
trois jours avant les familles seraient
prévenues que nos entrons en zone rouge
et la veille les familles et les élèves
seraient prévenus à 17h et nous serons
en effet quelles écoles et quelles
établissements scolaires seraient privés
d'électricité cela s'appelle là encore
le principe de précaution je vous
rappelle également que chaque année des
dizaines d'écoles et d'établissement
scolaires ferment de manière inopinée
par exemple suite à une chute de neige
c'est ce type là d'informations que nous
voulons fournir aux familles de manière
raisonnable sans leur faire peur merci
beaucoup monsieur le ministre la séance
des questions gouvernement est terminée
je vous propose de suspendre la séance
15 minutes et nous continuerons après
avec la déclaration du gouvernement
relative à la politique de l'immigration